hello everyone welcome to the may 2021
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast may
already 2021 it's been a long year uh
for me i'm sure for
almost all of you also i'm vaccinated
now though that's good
light at the end of the tunnel and all
that uh i even went into
my office at caltech where i'd like
actually just to do work not to pick up
mail or whatever
and uh which i had not done in over a
year so that's a sign of normalcy
returning
not a very optimistic sign yet there's
no one else around basically they're
still clamping down
quite heavily on the number of people
who can be in the same place at the same
time so
working remotely working from home is
actually still more efficient
at this point but hopefully you all are
out there getting your vaccines if you
can
the united states here has been doing
pretty well at getting uh
vaccines into arms shots into arms and
so hopefully wherever you are
you can get it also and we can get the
pandemic over with
so on to the ask me anything questions
uh as most of you know
this is a benefit for supporters on
patreon where they can ask
questions uh and then the answers are
given out to the patreon
audience right away and then a week or
two later will be given out publicly
you can become a patreon supporter
yourself by going to patreon.com
sean m carroll it's quite affordable
dollar an episode or whatever you want
to offer if you want to do more than
that then that's
great um you don't really get many
benefits you get ad-free versions of the
podcast and you get to ask questions for
the ama
mostly it's about just people who feel
that it's nice to be able to
give something back to someone who is
doing something providing content which
is
a nice thing that i try to do for
everybody we've reached a point where
there's too many questions so i cannot
answer all of them every month
so i try to pick and choose some and
group them together i have to say the
questions this month were really good it
was very difficult
to erase some of the questions i did not
answer a whole bunch of
perfectly respectable very good
questions i think that the fact that not
every question gets answered now is
making people raise their games perhaps
about asking really good questions so
my apologies as always if i didn't
answer your question uh as usual it's
not mostly about the quality of the
question so much as
the interestingness of whatever answer i
might have to give
about that question and you don't know
you don't have any way of knowing
whether i have anything interesting to
say about it so don't feel bad if your
question is not
asked especially if the questions of the
form you know
tell us an interesting story about x and
i may not have an interesting story
that's a perfectly legitimate
kind of question to ask but don't feel
bad if i don't answer it just means i
don't have any interesting stories
there you go sometimes my life is
interesting sometimes it's not
we are having a different um strategy
this month trying something out a
different rule which is that
the questioners people asking questions
can put in the beginning of their
question that is a
priority question and if it's a priority
question then i guarantee
i will answer it i will try to answer it
anyway and
the only catch is you only get to do
that once in your life
so if you have one question you really
really want answered you can ask that in
the ama
as a priority question if you're a
patreon supporter i'll do my best to
answer it couple people did in fact
use that this month so we'll see what
that looks like but anyway lots of good
questions many good topics whole bunch
of things
let's go
[Music]
daniel westwater says if ufo sightings
are legitimate which i'm not suggesting
they are
do you think it's more likely they have
found a way to traverse the multiverse
and are actually
beings that live on earth in another
multiverse rather than
faster than light travel from other star
systems galaxies
so i would uh put here is the ranking so
i'm happy to go along with your
hypothesis that ufo sightings are
legitimate even though i think they're
clearly not
but i would say number one no fdl travel
nor universe hopping in any sense that's
my most likely possibility by like 99
um second most likely is faster than
light travel third most likely is
hopping between
universes there's no reason that you
need to travel faster than the speed of
light to go from one star system to
another you just have to be patient
right as i said before probably on these
amas
we have this picture that you know since
a human being
lasts a century or a little bit less and
it might take more than a century to get
from one star system to another
you need to go faster than light to make
it interesting but that's clearly not
true once you solve
aging and uh getting older and dying of
old age things like that
right that is a much more tractable
problem technologically than faster than
light travel
solving aging is just a biology problem
faster than light travel is a
how do you violate the laws of physics
problem so i have
no trouble whatsoever in believing that
advanced civilizations will either
be able to live for thousands or
millions of years even as individuals
or just learn to put themselves to sleep
for the course of a journey again
very very tractable problems so even if
ufos are real i don't think you need to
violate the laws of physics to do it
of course the laws of physics as we know
them now might not be complete might not
be the final word so maybe it's possible
you can travel faster than the speed of
light there you go i'm willing to
consider that possibility probably it
would involve some kind of warp drive
kind of thing where you're taking
advantage of general relativity
rather than literally going faster than
the speed of light you're changing the
curvature of space times that it appears
that you're traveling faster than the
speed of light still not very realistic
in my mind but at least
something i can imagine hopping between
universes is something i cannot even
imagine
honestly like well i can't i can i can
imagine doing it i cannot imagine the
physical mechanism that would bring it
about so i would put that
last on my list of plausible things to
think about as i'm
constructing my bayesian priors for this
problem
second question i'm going to group two
questions together they're both about
infinite splitting of worlds in the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics
the first is from linu mizura and it is
labeled priority questions so as i said
this means i gotta answer it or at least
gotta try
and laneu is never allowed to answer to
ask a priority question ever again so
it's good that you know put yourself out
there the first time
the question is suppose i'm a working
physicist waiting for an atom
to decay the probability of the atom to
decay will increase as time passes what
happens according to many worlds
does an infinite number of copies of me
split as i wait since as time passes in
each fraction of a second there will be
a different
universe in which the atom might decay
then another related question comes from
christopheronski who says
i am almost able to imagine and believe
a finite or countable
countably infinite number of my versions
in the universe
but as far as i understand the wave
function of the universe swells
rather than branches for example a
nucleus emits a neutron and radioactive
decay
anytime in any direction how do you even
imagine a continuum of your cells
could that be an indication that space
is discrete
so both of these questions have to do
with the fact that in many worlds we
tell
a story where for example if you're
measuring something discrete like the
spin
of a particle that's either up or down
it's pretty simple to imagine the
universe
in one branch splitting into two but
when you have a continuous variable like
the position of a particle
or the time at which a nucleus decayed
then it sounds like you instantly have
an infinite number of universes right
in many worlds uh an unstable nucleus
has well in quantum mechanics let's put
it this way in quantum mechanics no
matter what your interpretation is
the wave function for an unstable
nucleus has a part of it that says i've
not yet decayed
and another part that says i have
decayed and that part that says i have
decayed
increases with time and so there's a
probability where you to measure it that
you would see the nucleus has decayed
but that part that says the nucleus has
decayed
is different depending on whether it
decayed now or a minute ago or 10 years
ago or whatever you know the actual
particle being emitted is doing
different things
so there's a continuum of possibilities
how do you deal with that in many worlds
and i admit that it does seem harder to
conceptualize but that's no barrier to
anything right yeah it's you
here's something where you have to trust
the math we'll get to this later in the
ama
sometimes you just have to believe what
the math says the
it's a it's a perfectly legitimate
question to ask
how should we think about the number of
worlds we're branching in or
or how to coarse grain etc when the
branching is continuous
and i think that the best answer is
exactly what you would do in calculus
for any other problem that goes back to
you know zeno and his paradoxes right
when you have something that is a
continuum don't talk about
exactly where you are in the continuum
talk about the probability you're
between
x and x plus delta x okay that's a
sensible thing to do
likewise like if you're if you have a
position just in classical mechanics on
the real line between zero and one
what is the probability that you're at
point three well it's it's zero because
point three is of measure zero between
zero and one but you can ask
what is the probability you're between
point three and point three one
right that's a sensible thing that will
have some possibly non-zero answer
likewise what you think of as a world in
many worlds when there are continuous
variables
you should think about the set of worlds
in which
the nucleus decayed between time t and t
plus delta t okay that's a sensible
thing to think about
the number of worlds in that interval is
infinite in some sense
but you can't tell the difference
between them if delta t is very very
small so you sort of group them all
together
david wallace talks about this more if
you're interested in the details in his
book
the emergent multiverse so i think i
asked bo
answered both questions there then we
have gerard droiven who also
asks a priority question and uh it says
in a short youtube video called the big
bang and creation myth
you suddenly hold up your hand and show
i presume this means me although i have
no idea
what youtube video is being referred to
here you suddenly hold up your hand
and show the scale maybe it doesn't need
me i really don't remember this at all
show the scale of our visible universe
compared to the whole universe
and i think i didn't hear the word maybe
when you said
it is tiny the namely the our visible
universe my mind made it into a
compressed visible universe there
between your thumb and index finger
so i thought of the big bang which was
tiny in its first moments so
time in there would feel different than
the time we experience on earth today
because it was tiny and compressed
so for the big bang inflation would not
occur at top speed
as has been calculated but since time
feels different when you're compact and
solid
it would have taken ages at least the
big bang had eyes and a brain
to sense its night sky so the question
is does it make any sense to have
thoughts like this
except that it is fun for me as a
non-scientist is there any touch of
reality
to it so i think that uh
there's two things just to be super
clear a clarification first the first
thing
is that i have no idea how big the
universe is beyond
our visible universe uh we have a very
good idea of how big the visible
universe is
beyond that it might go an inch
in every direction past that and then
suddenly stop that's possible
we'll find out one you know uh
microsecond later when when the horizon
grows a little bit
but it might grow you know it might be
twice the size of the visible universe
it might be 10 to the 10 to the 10 to
the 10 size
times the size of the visible universe
we have no idea
we can guess and that's okay so maybe
what i
should have said or tried to say or
whoever you're talking about said
is that it is completely possible that
the observable universe is a tiny tiny
fraction
of the entire universe now this time of
the big bang stuff
it's just not true the time flows
differently or
moves at a different rate uh near the
big bang just the fact that things are
dense
um doesn't mean the time moves any
differently time moves at one second per
second
uh you have to specify the reference
frame of the clock and which is
measuring
the time but in the big bang cosmology
there is a rest frame right the rest
frame that we now see is the rest frame
of the galaxies and the microwave
background
that was true even during inflation
there was a rest frame for the inflaton
field
so there was a normal sensible way
to measure time and when we say
inflation happened at whatever it was 10
to the minus 33 seconds
that's measured in that reference frame
sharon says the politics of our
post-world war ii world has been
dominated by nation-states that are
sovereign unto themselves
currently however we are facing crises
that are global in scale
like climate change and the current
pandemic we're all living through do you
think
the institution of nation states can
effectively deal with global problems
without developing into a worldwide
tragedy of the commons
or do you think an international body
that actually can hold them accountable
would be needed so i intentionally
uh agreed to answer this question
because i have no idea what the answer
is but it's a really
interesting and important question um i
mean it's
perfectly obvious that international
cooperation
would be a very very good thing i'm
tempted to say a necessary thing
but at least would be very very
advisable on a whole bunch of questions
whether it's
climate change resource management uh
pandemics
uh nuclear proliferation bioterrorism
you know a whole bunch of different
things
there have been you know when i was your
age uh we were living in the era when
the european union was coming together
etc and there was uh
the uh iron curtain fell and
people were optimistic that we'd be
entering an age of more and more
international cooperation
uh things have gone backwards a little
bit since then as as you may be aware of
um i still think it'd be a good idea i'm
not sure that something as
all-encompassing as a world government
would be a good
idea you know governments work or at
least democratic governments work
when the people in the country under the
government
feel they have common interests right
people in pennsylvania are willing to
pay taxes to help people in idaho
in um they might not admit it but that
is the compact that's the social
contract that they're under
and i think that worldwide here in the
year 2021
uh people don't feel that way about
people in other countries
so you know democracy is an experiment
that requires buy-in you can't
impose it and if if we're thinking of a
sort of democratic world government
rather than just a world dictatorship
then we need to live in a world where
people want to live under an umbrella
common umbrella and i don't think that's
true right now i think the different
nation states want to
advance their own interests right um
even here in the united states i mean
we're not any better than anybody else
you know america first
is very popular amongst a lot of people
um and
both it's weird you know both political
parties have more or less come to a
consensus that we should be
protectionist
and put up trade barriers you know the
economists don't like it but the
politicians do so
i don't think we're close to that i
think that in the meantime we're going
to have a lot of
attempts at getting individual
agreements between different sets of
countries and things like that
um but that's that's hard to do so i'm
not really optimistic that we are quite
mature enough
to tackle these global problems in a
sensible way
i don't know how to make it different
there that's that's just my feeling and
i could be wrong this is not my area
pablo's papa giorgio says how do you
check your ideas in theoretical physics
you mentioned writing equations do you
then do proofs on paper numerical models
is there a social aspect of convincing
colleagues
basically what happens before someone
agrees to do an actual experiment
um yeah there's a great question
actually and you
you have almost put your finger on all
the things that happen the one
thing i would uh edit is we don't do
proofs
in theoretical physics usually like
sometimes you'll have an idea
for something that follows
straightforwardly from some assumptions
in a particular physical model and
you'll prove that it's true
there are some famous examples of things
like that but mostly
you sort of derive implications of your
equations right you say like okay if
this set of equations is true then we
should observe the following signal in a
dark matter detector or something like
that
so it's writing equations pencil and
paper or chalkboard or
tablet or whatever you want um certainly
it's talking to people a lot
right most if you if you go go on
archive.org
a-r-x-i-v dot org you can see all the
theoretical
physics papers and all the experimental
physics papers for that matter that are
currently being written
so you can see what they're like right
and on the theoretical side
most papers are written by
collaborations by small collaborations
on the experimental side they're often
written by
large collaborations but people work
together because they're reality checks
and also
theoretical physics is a little bit
modular like you can write a paper
together and different people can do
different parts of the calculation and
things like that
and then yeah you want to give a talk
right you're if you're invited to give a
talk you can talk about your recent work
and
people in the audience will be skeptical
and give you a hard time and you try to
defend yourself all of those things
actually happens um so it's very much a
bottom-up kind of thing right there's no
like pope of theoretical physics who
says you're right you're wrong
uh you work on it yourself and you try
to convince other people of it and then
you see how it goes
submit the paper get peer review all
that stuff all that comes into it
okay i'm going to group together the
next two questions because they are
about
universes where there's an infinite
number of fluctuations
uh long term through the history of the
universe so first anonymous
says in the idol game cookie clicker the
goal is to get as many cookies as
possible one of the ways you can get
cookies is through shipments of cookies
from the cookie planet
in brian green's book the hidden reality
he claims that if space is infinite
you can not only expect to find every
possible arrangement of matter
out there somewhere but there will be
infinitely many copies of each possible
arrangement
is it reasonable to assume that if space
is infinite there will be an infinite
number of cookie planets and similar
absurdities
simply because the laws of nature don't
technically forbid things like that from
existing
and then another question is from josh
who says it's a related question it's
not exactly the same
you've said that boltzmann brains could
not come into existence because the
quantum because the vacuum state is
never observed
what about non-vacuum quantum states
that are observed like my chair isn't
there some tiny probability of my chair
turning into a boltzmann brain
so the reason why these are connected is
because
there is a very plausible cosmological
scenario
in which the universe expands as it's
doing now
continues to expand forever because
there is vacuum energy a cosmological
constant
and within any one observable patch of
that universe
the local physics is like empty space
but at a certain temperature
okay there's a certain temperature you
can associate with an accelerating
universe it's a very very tiny
temperature
10 to the minus 30 uh kelvin or
something like that i forget the exact
numbers
um so but if you wait forever infinitely
long so the logic goes
then you will have fluctuations into all
sorts of different crazy things
including boltzmann brains including
these
configurations of materials that just
have the minimum requirement to be a
conscious
creature of some sort so i wrote a paper
with kim body and jason pollock a few
years ago that pointed out that
that scenario as it's usually thought of
relies on a misinterpretation of quantum
mechanics
it's just not true that empty space
fluctuates
uh in the vacuum even if it's at a
non-zero
temperature if you were to observe empty
space
it would fluctuate but there's no one
there to observe it because you're in
the vacuum
so in fact the future vacuum state of
the universe is static because there's
no there's nothing dynamically
fluctuating when we use
words like fluctuations in the quantum
mechanical vacuum
that's just because we're always
thinking classically we're always
thinking
of quantum mechanical states as kind of
like statistical superpositions of
different fluctuating classical states
but they're not they're really really
different so
these boltzmann brains that you might
worry about do not fluctuate into
existence in
the quantum mechanical vacuum if it's
truly the vacuum if you've actually
reached the vacuum state there are other
scenarios that are very similar in which
you don't reach the vacuum state and
then it's a little bit
different so the question was from josh
is there a tiny probability of your
chair turning to boltzmann brain yes
there is but it's very very tiny and the
point is that
we're going to reach the vacuum before
an infinite
amount of time has passed right so we
ordinary observers
cosmologically only exist for a finite
period of time
and the probability within that finite
period of time of your chair turning
into a boltzmann brain
is very very small even if you integrate
over that whole time
the reason why boltzmann brains are
talked about fluctuating into existence
from the vacuum
is not because it's easier to get a
boltzmann brain from the vacuum it's
because the vacuum lasts forever
so if there's even any non-zero
probability you multiply the non-zero
rate
of making these brains by the infinite
amount of time you spend in the vacuum
and you get a non-zero in fact an
infinite number
of boltzmann brains produced if they
were produced at all that's what it
would be
but here in the ordinary universe you
can get random crazy quantum
fluctuations they're just really really
really unlikely
likewise for anonymous question if space
is simply infinitely big
that doesn't guarantee that everything
happens somewhere
it could be it's compatible with the
fact that everything happens somewhere
but you know you might put restrictions
on what happens
so if in other words if space is
infinitely big
it might be infinitely big but with the
feature that the same thing happens over
and over again
right um it could be just like a
checkerboard
extended forever and ever and ever if a
checkerboard is made of black squares
and white squares
you're never going to get a green square
even if you extend it infinitely far
so it depends on the specific way in
which matter is arranged uh in an
infinitely big space time
if it's infinitely fluctuating then yeah
then you're going to get
cookie planets you're going to get all
sorts of crazy things
this is all of course just completely
speculative things that we don't have
any
right to talk about uh from the basis of
what we know empirically about the
universe
but we can sensibly try to say what fits
in the best with what we
understand within the universe that we
do see and what happens when we
extrapolate it that's an okay thing to
do
bendy bruce says how do you feel about
the amount of investment the richest men
in the world are pouring into space
travel
well i have mixed feelings i think uh to
be honest you know i'm in favor of space
travel
i'm in favor of both exploring space
scientifically and you know increasing
the likelihood that human beings can
live
and travel into space i think that's a
good thing overall
i don't think that the concentration of
wealth that we currently have in the
world
that gives a handful of people
the right to decide how that's going to
happen
is a sensible way to run an
establishment you know
i do think that i would rather just have
big taxes on those people and take a lot
of their money so they're still
only super rich not filthy crazy rich
and
then we can collectively decide what to
do with the money that we collect
maybe help some poor people maybe invest
in science maybe invest in education
maybe invest in space travel
i think that's just uh in a in in you
know
as many people have pointed out no one
becomes a multi-billionaire
without help right you don't become a
multi-billionaire just by
um going out into the fields and using
your muscles or
by you know sitting alone using your
brain you use it because there's a
system
that allows you to do certain things and
talent helps of course
but uh the system has to be set up for
you to make a whole bunch of money so
the system should benefit the people who
are in that system should benefit as
well
i think okay the next two questions i'm
going to grouping together grouping a
whole bunch of questions together here
today
the next two questions are about bell's
theorem in different senses so ross
hastings says
as one of the few people in history who
managed to make einstein look like a
knob
one would imagine jon stewart bell would
be a bit more famous than he is and i
can't help but wonder if the reason is
because of how difficult it is to
understand what he did and how he did it
i've seen videos featuring demonic
clowns etc
being a master of wizardly explanations
i figure that if anyone can show us what
it all really means it's you
and then joe gravinsky says could you
explain bell's theorem that is the same
question
said in fewer words can you explain
bell's theorem and why it eliminates the
possibility of hidden variables are
there other reasons why hidden variables
have
been ruled out so i need to undo a
couple of assumptions in both of these
questions number one
bell's theorem did not eliminate the
possibility of human variables
number two bell did not make einstein
look like a knob um einstein
all everything that he said about
quantum mechanics sort of in um
for print right uh was very very
sensible you know it's not all right you
know
everyone makes mistakes including
einstein but you know he was on the
right track
it was einstein who gave us the epr
experiment
that led bell to invent his inequalities
right without einstein he wouldn't have
gotten there
um so to i'll do my best in a very quick
period of time because it is subtle
bell's theorem but i don't think that
the fundamental thing is difficult to
understand
honestly the idea is simply look if you
have a quantum if you have a system that
consists of two parts one part is
somewhere another part is somewhere else
so they're very far apart from each
other okay
and you're gonna do measurements on
these two parts of the system
uh they could be you know classically
they could be perfectly correlated if
there was some
event in the past right that said well
i'm gonna
i have two balls red ball and a blue
ball and i'm going to send one to the
left and one to the right i'm not going
to look which way they go
then obviously there's a classical
correlation once you look at one of them
oh it's the red ball then you know the
other one
is blue etc right so classically they
can be perfectly correlated
but in quantum mechanics you have this
opportunity and this is the important
part so let me just skip to the skip
ahead the point of bell's theorem is
that quantum mechanically you can not
know what answer you're going to get
when you measure either one subsystem or
the other
but there can be correlations between
the different things as you know
from epr from the sort of alice and bob
with their spins
example they can be perfectly correlated
right these two different things you can
have a spin that is either up or down
the other spin is also either up or down
and you can know with 100 certainty
that if you observe one up the other
will be down and vice versa
so the tricky part of bell's theorem is
that you don't
have to observe the spin in the same
direction
right when we say you're observing the
spin up or down and there's 100
correlation between them
we're imagining that you're assuming
you're measuring both spins along the
same axis
like the z axis typically okay and then
what quantum mechanics says if
is if alice measures her spin and it's
up in the z
direction and then bob measures his it
would be down but what if bob measure
says along the x-axis
right then it might be 50-50 then it
would be 50-50 whether it's going to be
up or down
so bell says well what if i just look at
all the different ways that i can
measure
the spin right i mean what would the
correlations be
and what he proves is that in quantum
mechanics there will be greater
correlations
between those two things that you can
possibly measure um
than you can possibly reproduce in a
purely local theory
okay by purely local theory we mean both
uh what exists in the world
exists only at local locations in space
right there's there's a spin here
there's a spin there and also that
signals cannot travel faster than
the speed of light so you cannot touch
a system in one place and instantly have
it um
affect something somewhere else so what
bell's theorem says is that
the quantum mechanical correlations even
if they're not perfect
which they're not if you measure a spin
up and a spin x you're not going to get
perfect correlations uh
with with those um but they exist there
are some correlations and they will be
better
in quantum mechanics than they possibly
could be in a local theory
now the word local is hugely important
there that's the entire point of the
theorem
is the word local in there i did not use
the words hidden variables
there anywhere right so what bell's
theorem rules out is the possibility
that einstein did want
although he never explicitly wrote down
a model he wanted to imagine that
someday we would find a hidden variable
theory that was local
where both the variables and their
interactions were entirely local
and bell's theorem says you can't do
that that does not prove that einstein
was a knob because einstein didn't claim
to do it
einstein hoped it was possible but uh he
said now
it's not really um he never actually
proposed a model to do it all he says is
the quantum mechanics didn't fit his
criteria for what he thought
um things should be okay so there are
non-local
hidden variable theories that's what
bohmian mechanics is
or de broy bone theory as it's sometimes
called pilot wave theories
these are all theories where what one
particle does
influences another particle non-locally
and that's a hundred percent compatible
with the observation and it's a hidden
variable theory
okay so hidden variable theories are
fine they just have to be
non-local whether or not you count many
worlds or something like that as
non-local
is trickier i mean that depends what you
mean by local depends on how you do the
branching of the wave function i don't
really think it's a very interesting
question so i don't care that much
but that's the point of bell's theorem
that you can't get
in a world with a unique outcomes so in
other words with not not in many worlds
but in a world where experiments give
you unique outcomes
there's got to be some non-locality
going on somehow
maybe there is there you go okay the
next question
is oops i lost where i am there we go
i'm going to group two things together
once again because these are on
branching of the wave function
and irreversibility so ron jacobson says
entanglement and branching of worlds or
collapse the wave function if you like
sound like an irreversible event is it
and
is this fundamentally relevant to
increase in entropy and the arrow of
time
and then also siraj rajan says are there
quantum mechanical interpretations that
satisfactorily explain the arrow of time
of our universe so let me do suraj's
question first
the arrow of time of our universe is
explained
by the fact that entropy was low in the
past right
entropy was low near the big bang that's
all you need that explains
that in the typical understanding of
what entropy is and how physics works
that explains it so maybe what you mean
is are there quantum mechanical
interpretations that explain why the
early universe had low entropy
no not as far as i know there are
quantum mechanical interpretations that
have intrinsic time
asymmetry in them where the rules of
physics are not the same going forward
and time is backward
for example objective collapse models
are like that you have models
like what are called grw theory and
roger penrose's theory
where wave functions simply collapse
they really do collapse it's not just an
apparent
collapse it's a real thing and they
collapse only going forward in time
so there is a very clear unambiguous
violation of time reversal symmetry in
these models
by itself that does not explain the
arrow of time in our universe because
if you started the universe in thermal
equilibrium
so with a high entropy state it would
just stay high entropy even if you had
collapsing wave functions
so you just have high entropy forever
that's not the arrow of time at all
no matter what happens no matter what
your theory of quantum mechanics is you
have to explain why the early universe
had
low entropy and no no attempt to
interpret quantum mechanics does that to
get to ron's question
um yeah the branching of the wave
function is exactly an irreversible
event and
why does it happen toward the future and
not the past well because the
wave function of the universe was
incredibly low entropy
at early times now i say that it's true
what i just said
but i shouldn't give the impression that
it's clear
you know we're we're we would like to
understand much better
what exactly are the features of the
wave function in the early universe
that give rise to the branching
structure that we have okay so
classically the fact that the early
universe needed to have low entropy
to make the arrow of time is much better
understood than the quantum mechanical
version
i don't think it's especially hard but
it's just that you know the
simple examples where we understand many
worlds very well
are laboratory-like experiments right
where we have a clear
division into system and environment and
we have decoherence in the whole thing
in the early universe it's not even
clear what the right degrees of freedom
are how to divide the world into system
and environment all that stuff becomes a
little bit trickier what do you mean by
low entropy
so there's work to be done there but
basically the answer is yes it is
it is not an explanation of the arrow of
time
but it but the fact that branching
happens toward the future rather than
the past is a
consequence of the arrow of time the
arrow of time is sort of more
fundamental
than that fact okay two more
uh questions grouped together and these
are superficially not exactly
asking about the same thing but you'll
see the relationship rob butler says
as i was daydreaming last week while
agitating my morning coffee i noticed
the gentle rocking of my mug had created
two perfect spiral galaxies in the milk
froth
is it possible that the universe's
missing gravity isn't due to a particle
but rather an extrinsic force acting on
or within the universe
similar to a centrifugal or coriolis
type effect
and then maximum alexandrovic says
recently after a jogging session i've
noticed something that caught my
interest in my sports tracker app
it shows a diagram of every training and
where whenever the altitude above sea
level
rises my speed drops which is obvious
it's harder to run uphill you slow down
but those two values when compared
together resemble a quantum harmonic
oscillator
whenever the real part of the wave drops
the imaginary part goes up
so this is a long shot but i can't stop
thinking about the existence of
additional spatial dimensions which you
mentioned as a possible result of the
recent muon affair in your solo episode
could this correlation be a possible
macroscopic hint
for something like that or is it my only
my vivid imagination
so uh besides the fact that these are
poetic little stories being told here
the common thing about these two
questions is
um trying to draw inspiration from a
common everyday occurrence to some deep
feature of the universe
which in principle is a good thing to do
totally you know
respectable kind of line of reasoning
to do but here's the problem the problem
is that these
these systems creams rolling into coffee
or you jogging up and down the hill
these are so simple
these systems they're uh very common toy
models right
they're they're they're paradigmatic
they're examples of
simple kinds of physical behavior so you
expect
very very similar kinds of behavior in
wildly unrelated things
right the phenomena you're looking at
here are sufficiently simple
swirls and sine waves
these are going to appear all over the
place right in context that really don't
have any deep fundamental true
connection with each other
at all so in both cases i'm going to say
no this is not going to work
uh you know the gravity that we use to
understand dark matter
is general relativity it's very very
well tested there's no room
in our galaxy which is very very tiny
compared to the whole universe
for something acting on it from the
outside to other than just
the gravity of the stuff to be causing
this
rotation curves to be like they are and
as you know
um if you well as i've said over and
over again let's put it that way maybe
you don't know but um dark matter the
best evidence for dark matter comes from
the cosmic microwave background
not from galaxies so if you want to get
rid of
dark matter explain the cosmic microwave
background that's what you have to do
and for the jogging up and down you know
yeah it's a sine wave
there's lots of sine waves that have the
property that one variable
goes up and down and the other variable
also goes up and down but out of phase
uh many many many things like that has
nothing specially to do with quantum
mechanics or extra dimensions in
principle
that would be my answer okay sandro
stuckey says can a photon spontaneously
decay
into two lower energy photons and if so
is this process reversible
um this is a good question so the answer
is no roughly speaking it cannot happen
why not so you might think well if i
have one photon with a certain energy
uh then well let's put it this way
if i have a particle with a certain
energy and it could decay it's allowed
kinematically
to decay into lower mass particles
then it does eventually it might take
some time but eventually it will because
there's sort of more room
in phase space in the space of all
possible situations
for there to be multi-particle systems
than single particle systems
roughly speaking this is entropy
increasing there's more ways
for the system to be many particles than
just one particle
so if you have one photon with a certain
energy
couldn't you imagine it wouldn't that
logic tell you that it could decay into
two photons there's more ways to be two
photons than to be one photon right
but it doesn't work uh because the
photon is traveling at the speed of
light
basically so not only do you have to
conserve energy you also have to
conserve momentum
right the momentum is not not just a
number it's also a direction
so if you go through the math you might
temporarily think it could happen
a single photon with a single energy e
you might say well that could decay into
two photons also going at the speed of
light
in exactly the same direction with half
the energy each
right what's the difference between one
photon with energy e and two photons
with energy e over two
um and it even works out with
conservation of momentum but
one problem with that the sort of sort
of there's a technical problem with that
which is you haven't really
increased the phase space of what's
going on there's
zero phase space to go into because you
have to get exactly the energy and
momentum of both
photons to line up in exactly the right
way if the photons you decay into go off
back to back then their sum of the sum
of their two momenta
is not moving at the speed of light the
only way that their two momentum can add
up to moving the speed of light is if
they move in exactly the same direction
as the original photon did
so there's kind of no room for this to
happen but you might think well i don't
know i'm still not quite convinced
that's a little bit too persnickety for
me
well here's the other answer you also
have to conserve angular momentum
right not just linear momentum the
photon is a spin-one particle
can one spin one particle decay into two
spin-one particles
well not unless they are orbiting each
other with a total spin of one to get
rid of the other
spin one and that's not going to happen
if they're both moving in the same
direction
so once you take all of the conservation
laws into account
no one photon cannot spontaneously decay
into two if they could
we would notice we would have seen that
a long time ago
ender's headland says why is your
website called preposterousuniverse.com
everything you teach us is that the
universe is far from preposterous
looking forward to hear the hearing the
story behind this
well yes so uh spoiler alert it's a joke
i'm just kidding with preposterous
universe.com you know it came about
because
back when i first got my website um
i was also working on dark energy and
the accelerating universe and i wrote a
paper
called dark energy and the preposterous
universe because
at that time when it was still new and
shiny to have dark energy and to try to
explain it
we theorists were still sort of a little
bit um
shaken with the fact that there was a
non-zero cosmological constant
acceleration to the universe we didn't
expect that
we had good arguments based on
naturalness
that the cosmological constant should be
zero
so the point of calling the universe
preposterous is not that it
is preposterous it's that it appears
preposterous to us
is that there is a mismatch between our
theoretical
uh guesses as to what the universe is
going to be like and what the
experiments actually
show us so calling the universe
preposterous is not you know calling the
universe names it's calling us names
it's reminding
us that we're not done yet trying to
understand the universe if
the universe cannot be preposterous the
universe is the universe it can it
cannot be unnatural
right the universe is by definition the
most natural thing
it can appear unnatural to us and that's
our fault that means that we need to do
better
okay another grouped question both about
string theory
rebekah lashua says is string theory a
quantum field theory can you speak a
little about the relationship between
string theory and quantum field theory
in general
and marcus curran says i have a question
about string theory the sense i get from
a layman's perspective is that its
selling point is in the beauty of the
theory
that it hints at a way to make known
physics and also a concept of quantum
gravity fall out from deeper
fundamentals
in a way that seems too good to be just
a coincidence the problem seems to be
the ideas are fiendishly hard to prove
experimentally
could it be that this is as far as we
get could be the string theory is
probably on the right track but is just
beyond the practical limit of what
science can do
in the real world so the quantum field
theory question is a very good one
because
as you you know study physics and you
learn about
particles and newtonian mechanics and
you learn quantum mechanics and you're
in quantum field theory you're
you're left with the idea that the
fields are more fundamental than the
particles
and in some sense string theory seems
like a step backwards from that
when you first learn string theory it's
like you're going back to the particle
language but you replaced particles with
strings okay
what happens to the fields the fields
were supposed to be progress
are we undoing that progress and
i'm not an expert i'm not a working
string theorist i've written a couple
papers
that are string theory adjacent but i'm
not a real expert in string theory so
i'm not the one to ask but i will give
you my impression here um
the best we have in terms of
understanding how string theory works
does not come from thinking of it as a
version of quantum field theory but at
some higher
stringy level there is something called
string field theory edwin has written
about it and other people have also
it just seems like a cumbersome
mathematical apparatus
that doesn't really help us in
understanding what string theory
actually predicts
but we also you know since the second
super string revolution in the mid-90s
uh the motto is string theory is not a
theory of strings
either right there are higher
dimensional objects d
brains there are different numbers of
dimensions in only 10 dimensions but 11
dimensions where the theory can be
defined in and in 11 dimensions there
aren't strings at all
um and there's some underlying theory
that presumably isn't stringy at all
that gives rise to what we know of as
the famous five different kinds of
string theory
plus the sixth 11 dimensional super
gravity theory
as different low energy limits of some
big underlying theory called
m theory so and no one knows really what
the fundamental
unique most beautiful definition of m
theory really is
so maybe uh string theory is just not
worth trying to make into a string field
theory
because there's something even deeper
that we don't know
or maybe we haven't figured out yet
the the efforts that have been made in
the direction of stringfield theory just
haven't been up to the task yet
uh i don't know again like this is not
quite my area so that's my impression
but you'd have to ask a real expert
about that and
to marcus's question um you know i
always
i always object a little bit when people
say including string theorists
when they put the selling point of
string theory as the beauty of the
theory
because the string theorists know
but the people who are listening them
don't that what they mean
is it's a purportedly very beautiful
explanation
for the data that we have it's not just
beautiful
right that who cares if something is
just beautiful but has no connection to
the world we observe
what makes string theories compelling is
that we know we live in a world
with space time with gauge theories for
the forces of nature
with gravity and curvature okay and
string theory gets us
all that stuff that's what makes string
theory interesting it gets us that stuff
in a
particularly beautiful way if you know
the theory and uh
and how it works so it's not just the
beauty
that is there and of course it fails at
getting us all the way to where we want
to go
no one has yet been able to sort of
explain why
we live in a world that is three plus
one dimensional with su 3 cross su 2
cross u1
forces and things like that that's
that's a problem for string theory so
yes it is possible that this could be as
far as we get i encourage you actually
to listen to
the podcast i did with brian greene
who's a working string theorist
and uh he was you know remarkably honest
about
exactly that fact he said yeah it's
completely plausible to him
that a few years from now whatever it is
um however many the number might be
string theory will be done in math
departments
you know the ambition of string theory
was absolutely to relate to the real
world of experiments you know to predict
things that we could not otherwise
explain in our
accelerators and so forth but that has
not happened
maybe it will happen tomorrow right who
knows but maybe it won't and if it
doesn't
then you could absolutely see people
deciding that
math departments were a more um
more appropriate place to put our string
theorists and maybe the mathematicians
will think we don't need as many string
theorists as the physicists do so
i think that's a very important question
for string theory to face up to we'll
see
what happens we'll see where it goes i
mean i should say this that actually
makes it sound overall
a little bit too pessimistic as as any
string theorist will tell you correctly
so
doing string theory even though it is
not latched on to experiment in any
direct way it has been an incredibly
fruitful source of ideas
ideas on black hole information on
dualities
gauge gravity dualities you know things
like that so
string theory is still useful to physics
even though it hasn't quite explained
the standard model or anything like that
quite yet
rodrigo nader says about the emergence
of consciousness or sentience
do you believe that consciousness
emerges from a certain condition some
neuron structure
or that it grows continuously like that
there are degrees of sentience would you
say that every living being
is a bit conscious um well you say yeah
you say every living being i would
certainly
i'm not pan psychist we talked about pan
psychism
on the podcast with philip gough pain
psychists really believe that everything
is a bit conscious right or at least has
some mental properties in some sense and
i don't
i don't go that way myself but i do
think that consciousness
is not an on or off switch either there
can be degrees of
consciousness or sentience absolutely i
think that i am more conscious than my
cats
my cats are more conscious than an
earthworm earthworm's more conscious
than a bacterium
bacterium is more conscious than a rock
okay now that's probably not just
because there is a
single spectrum of consciousness and you
just grow
as you go in that direction but there
are different aspects
of consciousness that come along the way
so i don't think it's
either on or off nor is it univalued
right there's different things you learn
to do
along the evolutionary tree that a
bacterium just it's not
so when you think about you know i don't
know um
uh imagining the future i don't think a
bacterium does that at all
imagining the future might play part of
a role in consciousness
and i can do it and i can do it better
than my cats and a bacterium can't do it
at all
okay so it's not that it's doing it a
little bit so i think it's very
complicated and we don't have the
complete definitions yet we should be
open-minded and
develop a phenomenological theory of how
those things come to be before deciding
ahead of time what they are
dan says have you ever considered
selling merchandise for the podcast for
example the logo on a t-shirt or cup
um i've considered it yeah considering
it is easy doing it is is more work
i even set up a shop i did i designed a
t-shirt
got that far and i made a t-shirt for
myself um
it's pretty awesome i have a mindscape
t-shirt i'm the only one who has a
mindscape t-shirt i'm not wearing it
right now but
it's a very good t-shirt you know if
there were huge
upswelling of demand for something like
that then i would do it
um but you know it takes time and i
gotta like i've said before in other
contexts
things that take time are not things i'm
very good at doing because
i have other things to do right i mean
you know i gotta make the podcast i
gotta write books i gotta do some
science gotta get some papers out stuff
like that
so again if there's huge demand for it
let me know
uh good two questions i'm gonna group
together about the quantization of time
fabian rostallen says one visualization
of multiple worlds is a sort of timeline
splitting into multiple
different timelines like a tree but if
time is also fundamentally quantum
so that not only the physical world as
we know it splits into multiple worlds
but time
itself splits into multiple times does
this mean that kind of visualization is
misleading
and robert rowlana says is time
quantized good so i'll take the second
one
first uh no as far as we know time is
just not quantized but then again as far
as we know space is not
quantized either you know in quantum
mechanics
so in just well not not quantum
mechanics in
good old non-relativistic quantum
mechanics like you need to do to explain
the hydrogen atom
or the double slit experiment okay when
you have a bunch of particles with wave
functions etc etc
space is not quantized in those theories
space is the location of a particle
is an observable you can measure it and
it's a continuum
you can get in principle any answer so
as we said before you should uh
think about is the probability what is
the probability the particle is between
point x and point x plus delta x because
it is not quantized
now once you get to quantum gravity
then we don't know maybe space is
quantized maybe not but we don't know
very much about quantum gravity at all
right we have ideas some of us have
ideas
but we shouldn't trust those ideas quite
yet
and time is even less likely to be
quantized than space you know
the schrodinger equation is the
fundamental equation of quantum
mechanics
and it has time in there as a smooth
continuous variable
uh it might not be the schrodinger
equation might not survive
into the fundamental theory of
everything there might be a better
version
and there are in fact options for what
that might be
but there's no established sense about
what how those options might work the
schrodinger equation is still the best
thing we have
people will often say you know the
planck time which you get by combining
planck's constant and newton's
gravitational constant and the speed of
light in the correct way
is somehow a quantum of time that's
just false that's no one thinks that no
one who knows what's going on thinks
that
it might represent a uh fundamental
measurement precision right a
fundamental limit to the precision that
you can measure
the time interval between two events or
something like that
but it does not imply that time is
somehow
discrete in any simple way and for
fabian's question
because the schrodinger equation does
have time in it
when we visualize the branching of
worlds as you know one branch
branches into two and you know draw them
going upward let's say on a diagram and
time is flowing upward
it is the same time it's not multiple
times
um it's multiple space times
but it is there's a single time variable
that is clicking off in the schrodinger
equation
that brings both of those space times
into existence so the visualization is
actually not that misleading
the only thing that could be misleading
about it is if you want to imagine that
the space
in between the different branches of the
wave function that you're visualizing
somehow exists that part is completely
crazy it's just uh we need to draw it
somehow it's not because there's really
anything in between the different
branches of the wave function
philip hurit herdlichka says
i would like to ask you a question about
the double slit experiment
let's have some neo-copenhagen psi
epistemic interpretation where the wave
function or really its square
is just a probability of finding a
particle at a given place
now in the double set experiment the
wave packet which is just a probability
of finding the particle
splits into two way packets due to the
slits and it interferes with itself
the question is if the wave packet is
not real
and there's only a probability of
finding the particle there then the
particle must have gone through only one
or the other slit so what causes the
interference if we have psi epsilon
interpretations
and the particle really only goes
through one slit what causes the
interference
um i don't know i really don't so
i i debated with myself philip about
whether or not
i should answer this question because i
don't have a good answer to it but
i can at least alert people to the
existence of the question
um what's going on here is that among
the
different possible options for one's
favorite interpretation of quantum
mechanics
there are options that are called
sciontic
where the wave function psi really
exists
you know here it is it's the fundamental
stuff of reality or at least part of it
so we've mentioned hidden variable
theories before in the hidden variable
theories
the wave function is part of reality and
the hidden variables are another part of
reality
in many worlds or in objective collapse
models it's just the wave function that
is reality
in the psy epistemic models what they're
saying
is that the wave function is just a
tool that we use to predict the
probability
of certain measurement outcomes in fact
in some versions like in cubism
different people can assign different
wave functions to exactly the same
physical system because they have
different amounts of knowledge and so
they they know different things about
the system and give it different
probabilities for doing things
now the question you're asking is don't
we have evidence from things like the
double slit experiment
don't we have evidence that the wave
function interferes with itself
probability distributions don't
interfere with themselves because
they're not real they're just you know
in
ways of measuring our ignorance but the
wave function does because it creates
slits it creates
interference patterns on the other side
of the double slit so what's going on
i don't know what is going on phillip um
here is
and i've tried i've tried to understand
what uh
psy epistemic people would say about
this but i'm not a psychedelic person
i don't spend that much time trying to
think about it because i have other
things to do
right i'm thinking about my theory that
i think is more likely to be right
so you should really ask one of them um
but i would
i think that what they would say is um
look
our job is to predict the outcome
on the screen our job is not to tell you
what's happening when we're not looking
at it right the idea of a psy epistemic
theory is to make predictions for the
experiences of observers
not to tell some mechanistic story about
what happens along the way
there may or may not be some mechanistic
story to tell
i think is what they would say but what
i care about is my ability to make
predictions and so if i use some
machinery to make predictions like a
wave function interfering
with itself that's fine i'm allowed to
do that but what i care about
is the predictions are the experiences
of observers that's what i'm after at
the end of the day
again don't trust me on this one i'm not
completely sure that's true but i think
that that is what they would say
anyway i'm not an expert because i don't
think that's a very fruitful way to go i
think that
the wave function really is real and you
know that's the better way to go
all right i'm gonna yet again group
these three questions together
you'll see why eric chen says any
updates on the physics of democracy what
is the main motivation behind this
project and what do you think are the
main sources of value
in bringing ideas from physics to the
analysis of political economic or other
multi-agent systems
luca mordecini says i first met you in
the great courses plus
with your courses dark matter and dark
energy the higgs boson and time
my question is do you intend to record
any new courses on that site
uh and herberg of it says do you have a
new teaching company course in the works
if you do what's the topic teaching
company and the great courses are the
same
company so you see why i've grouped
these together they're all about uh
questions about what i'm doing in the
future and you know i think that i let
my guard down a little bit here because
usually i just don't say anything about
what i'm working on in long-term
projects for the future because you know
sometimes they don't pan out you know
they don't happen or they don't happen
uh
in the time scale that you might want
them to happen or if they don't happen
at all
um but i have revealed that i am working
on a book called the physics of
democracy
and uh it's actually been delayed i'm
i'm very willing to say that
and it's been delayed for a couple
reasons one is
that i mean the major reason is
that when i went into it the physics of
democracy you know i had an outline i
had some ideas
and the idea is basically to use ideas
from the physics of complex systems
uh multi-agent systems emergent
phenomena
in uh multiple component aggregations of
things
to talk about political issues right and
i know that some people have worked on
this obviously but
i'm going to write i am going to write a
trade level book so i'm going to
talk about other people's interesting
work to sort of let people know
how a physicist would think about these
things so when i started to work on it
and started to go like from the
brief outline i had to real work you
know reading other people's stuff
talking to people
what i realized is there's an enormous
amount of work
in this area but it's just not labeled
as such
uh you know if you look up econophysics
on the internet or anywhere else
econophysics is a whole field i mean
there are textbooks in econophysics
right it's it's almost a joke
physicists going in and trying to do
economics
um but there are no political physics
books
and so you might get the impression that
no one works on it but
lots of people work on it they just
don't call it that so
uh it turns out that i have more work to
do than i thought i would
uh which is fine that's actually good
news right i'm gonna learn a whole bunch
of fun things like half the reason why
you write these books so you can learn
new fun things
yourself so it's going to take more time
to do that the other reason is we had a
pandemic
even with the original plan um
i was still definitely planning on
talking to a lot of people
traveling you know picking people's
brains and things like that
spending time at the santa fe institute
you know we have an idea of maybe even
have a workshop at santa fe
on exactly this topic none of that
happened
none of that happened in uh in in the
time scale that would have been
reasonable so we've delayed it
uh until later um what i am hoping to do
again i'm
talking out of turn i really shouldn't
say this but the hope
uh don't hold me to any my hopes because
they can go away but the hope is
to instead write the biggest ideas in
the universe
right the videos that i did uh last
summer
where i talk about the classical
universe and the quantum mechanical laws
of physics and field theory and
normalization and then a little bit
about complex systems and criticality
and things like that all that stuff
um what i really realized while doing
the videos was that it's a
level of discussion that just doesn't
exist
out there almost not at all i mean the
one place
maybe that tries to do something like
that is roger penrose's book the road to
reality
but um you know it's it's
idiosyncratically penrosean
okay uh and the idea of really doing
modern physics
but giving some of the equations right
not teaching people how to do you know
the product rule for
derivatives or anything like that or you
know complex contours
uh contours in the complex plane to do
integrals you know none of the
nitty-gritty
techniques you use to do mathematical
analysis and theoretical physics
but enough of the conceptual framework
to say oh look here's a derivative
here's an integral it's not that hard
learning what a derivative is
learning what an integral is is very
easy
learning how to calculate them is very
hard
and so you either there's a bifurcation
there's our there are popular level
discussions
where you just don't talk about that
stuff right it's just words no equations
equations are considered scary
or you do the textbook right you just
learn everything like you're going to be
a professional physicist
and what i tried to do in the videos was
to say well there's a middle ground
where i can just tell you what the
equations mean
without telling you how to manipulate
them without pretending you're going to
grow up to be a professional physicist i
want to give you the ideas
and so i would like to develop that into
a book that's a that is a project that
is going to go
first and then physics of democracy
second for the great courses or the
teaching company
um again yes i would like to do another
uh course for them and the obvious thing
to do will be
quantum mechanics um i wrote a book on
that right something deeply hidden
so many worlds maybe particularly
because they have a lot of courses on
quantum mechanics already
if they didn't i might just do a course
on quantum mechanics in general but they
have quantum mechanics courses that are
perfectly good they don't need that
so i might just do a course on um
some version of what i talked about in
something deeply hidden so it would be
about
quantum mechanics itself but only a
little bit and then why many worlds is
such an attractive version of quantum
mechanics and why the foundations of
quantum mechanics are important in the
first place
maybe a little bit about emerging space
time and stuff like that who knows but
that is the hope
all right no more talk about future
projects until they're
i like to have them done you know
otherwise i'm just putting pressure on
myself
all right what's next fred alexander
says
people are always searching for meaning
i.e our purpose
from the big bang to decaying particles
the least common denominator seems to
boil down to entropy
is increasing entropy at the core of why
all things happen
in our universe so in a sense yeah
yeah actually i'm not quite sure what
answer you were expecting here but um
there's a sense in which the answer to
this question is yes but let's be clear
about what
that sense is so for one thing it's
crucially important to separate out as i
always try to do
time as a notion as a as an idea
time you know what time is it now how
long will this thing take
stuff like that from the arrow of time
okay
so when i say that entropy is
responsible the fact that entropy is
increasing
is responsible for the arrow of time
that this should not be translated in
your mind to
increasing entropy is responsible for
time although that happens a lot i see
people sort of
uh paraphrasing things i say in that way
and that's just wrong right i mean
there's no arrow of space
but there's still space time exists
and it also separately has an arrow
those are two things so i would
i would not say exactly the phraseology
you used there
is increasing entropy at the core of why
all things happen
you know we could have a universe in
which time existed and things happened
but entropy didn't increase right it'd
be very very different universe than
ours but there would still be time and
all that stuff
okay having said all that having cleared
that brushwork a little bit
um if there are
for anything that does happen in the
universe if that thing
has the property that it does not happen
equally well forward or backward in time
then entropy lies behind it that is what
i would
say okay um even the expansion of the
universe
only happens one way but it could happen
the other way you could imagine running
it backward and there'd be nothing weird
about that
right so that is not to do with entropy
whereas
you know an ice cube melting you can't
you don't really imagine that ice cube
would unmelt spontaneously that's not
something that you would expect to
happen in the world that does have to do
with entropy
when it comes down to human beings
meaning and purpose
well if you have a purpose generally i
i suspect your purposes are related to
things that will happen in the future
[Laughter]
you don't have as a purpose i would like
the following thing to have happened in
the past
because you have no causal leverage over
the past
the past is done with right the future
you think you can
affect by your doings here and now
and so the future is the thing about
which you could have a purpose
and i think that's a fundamental
difference between the past and the
future that is ultimately due
to entropy and it's because entropy is
increasing that we think
of the past as being fixed and the
future as being
influenceable so whenever you talk about
things like purpose or meaning etc
in the background of those discussions
is the fact that
we treat the past and future very very
differently and the reason why is
because entropy is increasing so the
short answer is yes to your question
john schoening says if particle position
momentum uncertainty
can be explained completely classically
due to matter waves and fourier
transforms
why does applying that same logic to
water waves
seem inconsistent since an individual
ripple in a wave of water seems to be a
concrete thing as opposed to a more
conceptual infinite sum
so well this is so i don't know how much
how much background the
people have in general here um you've
heard of the uncertainty principle
that in quantum mechanics you cannot
have a quantum state for which
if you were to measure either the
position
or the momentum you can know ahead of
time
what either one of them will be to very
very high precision that is not allowed
in quantum mechanics
there are quantum states for which were
you to measure the position you can
predict ahead of time what answer you
will get
there are quantum states for which if
you were to measure the momentum
you can predict ahead of time what you
will get there are no quantum states for
which you could predict both
accurately ahead of time that's the
uncertainty principle delta x
the uncertainty in x times delta p
is at least h-bar or h-bar divided by
two something like that and
that sounds very mysterious and you know
a lot of a lot of crazy talk has been
expended thinking about the uncertainty
principle once you know what a wave
function is
all that craziness goes away um it has
to do with fourier transforms and
it has to do with the fact that wave
functions are waves and
if you think about the wave as a wave in
position okay so what you mean is when
you have a wave function you don't
attach a wave function both to position
n momentum
you draw the wave as just a function of
position
and then the momentum is the wavelength
right or the frequency really of
that wave that you've drawn as a
function of position so
if the wave that you've drawn for
position is highly peaked around just
one value
then in terms of momentum it's a sum
of as the as the questionnaire says it's
an infinite sum
of many many different momenta and vice
versa so
classical what we call fourier analysis
reducing a wave to its individual
frequencies makes the uncertainty
principle
seem almost like not even a physical
option
just a mathematical necessity right it
couldn't have been any other way
so why isn't the same thing true for
something like a water wave or something
like that right
well there is a difference the
uncertainty principle is not classical
at all there is a analogous things for
classical waves you cannot have a
classical wave
who's that is both you know localized
in position and localized in fourier
space
the difference is that in quantum
mechanics position
and momenta are both things you can
observe and get specific answers for
right so there's a relationship between
that wave and the outcomes of
observations in quantum mechanics that
is not there
in classical mechanics in classical
mechanics if you have a water wave you
just observe the water wave that's it
in quantum mechanics you there's a wave
but you don't observe the wave
you see either the position or the
momentum observable
and so it's that relationship between
the fact that you cannot localize both
in position and momentum
and the fact that position momentum are
both things you can observe
that gives the uncertainty principle its
oomph in some sense
tim kennedy says how do you feel about
the new political leadership in the
united states are you pleased with the
first 100 days
um i think fairly pleased yeah you know
i mean honestly by any
reasonable standard given the previous
four years one has to be
over the moon happy with the current
political leadership in the united
states
and you know just so i'm very very clear
about this and i know people can
disagree with me that's fine but i want
everyone to know what i mean when i say
the words whether or not you agree with
the words
donald trump was just you know the worst
president we've ever had in the united
states and it's not because of his
policies i mean his policies weren't
that great i could complain about his
policies
it is because of the complete lack of
respect for what you call democracy and
the institutions of government
uh the corruption the incompetence the
um uh the cult of personality
the you know the the the never putting
the american people
first before the interests of donald
trump and his family
completely treading over all the norms
of how things happen
in the in the democratic government all
that stuff
um still to this day it's may still not
even accepting that he lost the election
right that's what makes him the worst
president of all time he's still saying
that you know it was a cheat
and people believe him and this has done
incalculable damage
to the project of democracy in the
united states of america
it democracy is hard enough to get it to
work
when everyone believes that we are in a
functioning democracy because people
disagree with each other about what the
policies should be but when you have
substantial numbers of people
who will just never accept the outcome
of an election that doesn't go their way
the democracy can't work and that's
enormously more damaging
than any particular policy that donald
trump might have had
so it's not that you know i'm democratic
or republican i
i do end up on the democratic side most
of the time
but my objections to donald trump
weren't that he was a republican in fact
he wasn't a republican right he was a
democrat for a long time in his life
and i'd like to say it this way
imagine some horror scenario in which
donald trump had stayed a democrat
and had run for president as a democrat
and had won the nomination uh to be the
democratic
nominee for president and the
republicans had nominated someone really
terrible like ted cruz
you know would i have voted for the
democrat rather than ted cruz even if
the democrat were donald trump
and the answer is not only in that
situation would i have voted for ted
cruz
i would have very loudly announced to
everyone that i was voting for ted cruz
and i would have donated money to ted
cruz's campaign
against donald trump ted cruz is a
terrible person and his policies would
have been terrible
but he would work within the system of
our democracy
much much better than donald trump would
have it's and i know how bad he is
but compared to donald trump he still
would have been good anyway
so just the restoration of a functioning
government
at all you know if you look at the press
conferences and so forth the press
briefings
um if you look at what kinds of
executive orders are being signed what
kinds of legislation is moving forward
all of that stuff it's just a
back to normal feeling that is
enormously helpful
in terms of actual actions on the ground
you know the we went from one of the
worst
um policies for dealing with the
pandemic
to one of the most effective vaccine
distribution policies in the world so
that's pretty good
um they're finally putting actual effort
into restoring the economy and jobs
after the effects of the pandemic so
there's plenty of things you complain
about like i don't
agree with joe biden about everything or
even close to everything i think that
you know on certain issues
like as i already mentioned free trade i
think that trade should be a lot freer
than he's very protectionist
um uh immigration and the refugee crisis
he's done terrible at you know so i can
nitpick those things
but compared to the absolutely abysmal
rock bottom
presidential leadership that we had
before joe biden
he is uh unimpeachably wonderful there
you go that's what i would say about the
first hundred days
john smith says what scientific
discovery would disappoint you the most
so that's an interesting question
there's another one where i thought yeah
i thought about this like do i have
anything interesting to say about
this because in some sense the
respectable answer is
you can't be disappointed by scientific
discoveries
the world is the world right the
universe is the universe we don't know
what it is
we're discovering it we're not bringing
it into existence we're finding out what
it is by doing science and so every
scientific discovery teaches us
something new about the world
how can you be disappointed by that okay
but then
in the real world we're only human i'm
only human and i would certainly
prefer things to be some ways rather
than other ways
uh but i'm not yeah it is hard to think
because
basically if you think about it you're
rooting for certain scientific theories
to come true
because you think that they probably are
right because you you
sort of favor them in terms of your your
current tentative state of knowledge you
know
if uh i don't know if um the many
world's interpretation of quantum
mechanics was not true or if general
relativity was not true on large scales
that'd be really really interesting i
don't think it's going to happen
so in some sense i'm rooting for the
theory that i spend my time
thinking about but it'd be fascinating
if it weren't actually true
so the kinds of scientific discoveries
that would disappoint me
would be ones that somehow represented a
retreat
from intelligibility
in the universe right the whole reason
why science is so great is because
the universe is understandable it's hard
but we make
absolute progress and sort of features
of the universe that seemed
kind of inexplicable would be the worst
now of course what what counts is that
you know one of my favorite stories is
with joe polczynski the famous physicist
who passed away a couple years ago
um back in the day back in the mid 90s
when i was a postdoc
in santa barbara and joe and i joked
about the anthropic principle
and he said yeah if the cosmological
constant were ever discovered to be not
zero
this is in like 1997. if we discover
that cosmetic constant was not zero
i would resign from physics because the
only way to explain that
is uh with the anthropic principle and i
hate the anthropic principle
and so i said well okay if that happens
can i have your office and he said yes
and then like a year later they
discovered the cosmological constant
and not only did i not get joe's office
but he did not resign
and in fact he became a big booster of
the anthropic principle
he never really liked it like he boosted
it because he's a respectable
intellectually respectable scientist and
he said yeah we have it we have data
at the cosmos constant and the best way
that i have to account for that data
is with a multiverse you know i don't
need to like it it's the best scientific
explanation that i have to hand
so that's the kind of thing where you
learn something about the universe you
know
i'm not sure it's true it's it's
certainly not settled
but one could argue that the fact that
we found the cosmological constant
means that that lowers the hope
of finding a formula that once and
overall predicts
the cosmological constant because the
anthropic explanation becomes bigger
for me the version of that would be
something like dynamical collapse models
for quantum mechanics if you thought
that wave functions
really collapsed as an objective fact
and just randomly right like just every
so often a wave function collapses
and it only happens toward the future
not toward the past so it violates
reversibility also
that would just uh rub me the wrong way
if it were true i mean again i'd be
thrilled to have learned something about
the universe this is an experimental
question we're doing experiments to look
for this kind of behavior
and if it's there i'll believe it and
i'm not giving anyone my office um
but it's just so ugly in my mind so that
would disappoint me in that sense i'm
not quite sure i would i'm
i would probably think of another way to
think that it was really beautiful
because again the universe is the
universe presumably the universe uh
as if we understand it better uh we'll
grow to like it
honest stark says if i understand
correctly we are wondering where all the
anti-matter is how do we know that some
arbitrary star
is made of matter and not anti-matter so
the simple answer is that the universe
is not as empty as you think it is
okay if you think about galaxies that
are very very far apart forget stars you
know stars are
uh surrounded by interstellar gas and
dust and they would constantly be
running into each other if there was a
if a star were made of antimatter
and the rest of the universe were made
of matter that or even if they were 50
50
the matter and anti-matter would
constantly be hitting each other and
annihilating and giving off gamma rays
that's even true if individual galaxies
were matter and anti-matter they're
still an intergalactic medium
it's very verified it's very dilute but
the universe is big
so you can predict the amount of gamma
ray radiation in the background
light that would exist if galaxies were
half and half and it's way more
than what we actually observe to make
things worse
the universe used to be much smaller and
denser right and so if you say well now
i have a galaxy or whatever that is
anti-matter and another
one that it's matter and they're far
apart well in the past they used to be
right on top of each other
certainly that would be even more true
with stars so all this matter and
anti-matter would annihilate very very
quickly in the early universe
so we're very confident that what we see
in our observable universe
is almost all matter not anti-matter
thomas perzinski praziki says
imagine a star trek style transporter
with a twist
it disassembles a person and then
supposedly reassembles two identical
copies of them on transporter pads one
and two
you have been through this transporter
hundreds of times and every time you
were assembled on pad one
how do you decide whether to accept your
experience as a reasonable statistical
anomaly or to suspect there is something
else at play
so to repeat if we forget this scenario
correctly
you're told that when you get in the
transporter it's a 50 50 chance you go
to
transporter pad one or pad two but what
you actually observe is you're on pad
one every time
and so how do you judge what's going on
so i think that you know this is
a absolutely perfect case study for a
good bayesian analysis right
who cares what you're told you have a
prior
belief that the transporter really does
put you randomly on transporter pad one
or transporter pad two
and you have a prior probability that it
actually always puts you on transporter
pad one
and there's a prior probability will
always put you on transporter
transporter pad 2
and another prior probability that it
will alternate and you know all these
different things you have a set of ideas
of what the possible
credences you should put with all these
different theories are now maybe
the person who told you that it was
random is very believable and your
prior probability that you always go on
transporter that sorry your prior
probability that it's random
is 99.99 that's fine
but every time that you do the
experiment and you keep
appearing on transporter pad one you
just run it through basis formula
and basis formula gives you a way of
saying given this new data how should i
change my credences
so no matter how high your credence was
that the transporter is random between
pad 1 and pad 2
there will be a number of times you
appear on pad one
where you switch over from thinking it
was random to thinking you know what i
think it just sends me on
pad one every time but it should never
go to zero or one because you always
have more data you can collect in the
future that might change your mind
rob griber says or graber says what is
our current understanding of the initial
formation of magnetic fields in the
early universe
so i'm not going to give a good answer
to this because i don't know what the
answer is i don't know i don't think
there
is a current understanding there are
current models
but i do want to sort of raise
consciousness about this question
because it's an it's an interesting one
it's one that i've worked on
with my phd advisor george field we're
still thinking about
a different writing a different paper
about this updating some of our older
stuff
but the idea is that we have data that
seems to indicate there are
large-scale magnetic fields in the
universe not
huge like the actual size of the
magnetic field is quite small
i don't know exactly what the numbers
are but you can sort of measure the
average amount of magnetic field between
the galaxies and things like that or
even
large scale in galaxies and so they're
there
and you can ask where do they come from
and it's not
impossible to come up with scenarios to
get a magnetic field you know you
have a bunch of charges uh electric
charges moving around
and we know from maxwell's equations
that once you get charges moving around
you can make magnetic fields
so for a long time now there have been
theories of
batteries like galaxies acting like
batteries
winding up the magnetic fields and
amplifying them
the problem is it's just an incredible
nonlinear horrible mess
in magnitude hydrodynamics to ask you
know
starting with some tiny magnetic field
some seed field
in the early universe how it evolves in
a
situation as complex as a galaxy in a
galaxy you have
not just stars but you have gas and dust
and some of it's ionized some of it's
not you have supernovae going off and
they have their own magnetic fields and
you have neutron stars and black holes
and
it's a mess right so there are people
like me
who don't know anything about this messy
late universe stuff but do try to answer
the question
can we generate some primordial magnetic
fields
in the early universe with a phase
transition you know or something like
that
that would give you a starting point to
make magnetic fields and galaxies
but i don't think there's any accepted
model for how that is right now i think
that
knowing just the standard model of
particle physics there's no obvious way
to make that happen
maybe you need new physics maybe you
need new
um scalar fields or pseudoscalar fields
or something more exotic
to make those magnetic fields i think
that right now the problem is just too
hard there's no consensus
adrian says are there any parts of
physics that you never understood as
well as you think you should
what is your kryptonite um so i chose to
answer this question because it's a
short one
all parts of physics are parts that i've
never understood as well as i think
i should uh even the what parts that i
do there's always more to understand
right
you know i don't even have any degrees
in physics and that's a little bit of a
cheap both of my degrees
undergraduate and graduate are in
astrophysics so it's pretty close and i
took all the courses
but sorry i didn't take all the courses
i took all the courses that i thought
would be relevant
to my work in theoretical physics so i
took
um quantum mechanics and quantum field
theory and
general relativity and particle physics
in the early universe all those things i
took courses in those
but i i could get away without you know
i had extra courses to take because
there were required courses
on these in the astronomy side of things
and therefore i didn't take
some of the less relevant physics
courses like condensed matter physics
right
um statistical mechanics i didn't even
take which is ironic
now they do a lot of work on statistical
mechanics but so
there are absolutely aspects of those
fields especially condensed matter
physics uh
that i don't come anywhere close to
understanding as well as i would like
to now as well as i think i should
yeah you know what's who's to say should
i'm actually this is this is another
interesting aspect of the question
is i get why
you know elders in physics departments
want their students to get a broad-based
physics education because
all things being equal it makes you a
better physicist
but it's hard to predict exactly ahead
of time what skills
people will use in their careers and
some people just like being narrow
and are very very good at being narrow
and getting their narrow thing
done and other people don't like being
narrow but
would like to be brought in a different
way than their elders would like them to
be like maybe they want to be taking
courses in biology or in information
theory or in computer science
rather than particle physics or
condensed matter physics or whatever
so i don't have a list of things that
everyone should know
i think that you should know the things
you need to know uh to get ahead and
tickle your curiosity that's that's my
uh philosophy of these things nicholas
vyberg says
how could quantum field theory be
compatible with the idea that the
universe has a finite number of degrees
of freedom
given that a field has a value at every
point in space uh short answer is it's
not
compatible with that if the universe has
a finite number of degrees of freedom
then it is not described by a quantum
field theory
it might be approximately described by a
quantum field theory so that's the hope
so for those of us who think that within
our observable universe
there is a finite dimensional hilbert
space of quantum states
which you could translate into saying
there are finite number of degrees of
freedom
that's exactly well it's not exactly but
it's very very analogous to saying
there are finite number of atoms and
molecules
of air in the room that i'm in right now
but i can describe them approximately as
a continuous fluid
as a gas right that's a good emergent
approximation at low energies and large
distances
likewise we would hope that whatever
this
quantum description is that is finite
dimensional has
as a low energy approximation quantum
field theory right that's what it would
have to be but it couldn't strictly be a
quantum field theory all the way down
chris rogers says i live in london
should i move to la
well chris uh it depends you'll be
surprised to learn that it depends on
many many things
so i love both places london and los
angeles are two my favorite cities
they're quite different the weather is
different you may have heard about that
los angeles is expensive london is
crazily expensive
so in los angeles you get a much better
house for the same amount of money than
you could in london let's put it that
way
um politics is quirky in both places i'm
not gonna
draw a distinction there you know there
are
there are different sort of quality of
life issues or everyday life issues that
are just
different you know the united states is
in many ways
a culture of convenience everyone has a
car
the supermarkets sell everything amazon
sells you everything
um but it can be a little harsh right
you know healthcare
not easy to pay for sometimes there's a
sort of
you know get it for yourself kind of
attitude in the united states that we
have sometimes rather than we're all in
it together
um i i like los angeles a lot
uh it it is a wonderful city lifestyle
wise
the food is great um the weather like i
said is great but also there are
cultural institutions that are quite
good
but overall you know food is also really
good in london and the cultural
culture in london is probably better
overall in terms of
universities uh art um
music and theater things like that
london probably has it over la
the typical restaurant you will walk
into is way better in los angeles than
it is in london
but the best restaurants in london are
probably better than the best
restaurants
in los angeles um and los angeles you
know even though it's a wonderful big
city it's
it's spread out as a big city you
you can't do in los angeles what is very
easy to do in london or paris or new
york or tokyo which is
go downtown and wander around right and
and something good will happen you'll
discover something good like
in los angeles there's a million great
things going on
but you have to know where they are and
you have to figure them out so you
either have to like live here for a long
time
or you have to have guidance on what to
do
you're also in the middle of the
entertainment industry which has its
benefits
uh you know it's a whole different kind
of creativity
than you get in in other fields um it's
a unique place like no
no place is the center of the
entertainment industry quite like los
angeles is
so i think it's tied you know you know
things like weather and cost of living
seem very uh down to earth concerns but
there are important concerns and la wins
on both of those
food depends on how much you want to
spend on the food
you know tacos are much better in la but
the beef wellington is much better in
london
so i like both of them you know you
couldn't go wrong it depends on what you
want to do for a living which i don't
know
so good luck with that randy roberts
says
short version of my question is the
calculation of the entropy of a physical
system
subjective or objective and the answer
is yes
that's the short version of the answer
because the word entropy has different
definitions there are different
ideas to which we attach the word
entropy
there is a subjective definition which
is to say
that entropy is somehow a measure of our
ignorance of the specific details of the
system so
classically you can know that
there is a system like the air in this
room that has a microscopic state
microscopic we don't mean small we just
mean all of the data
the position and location the position
and velocity of every single
atom and molecule in the gas right but
we don't know it
so we have some probability distribution
over what those positions and velocities
are and you can use that probability
distribution to calculate an entropy
that entropy is a hundred percent
subjective it reflects your knowledge of
the system
but then there are other contexts in
which entropy is perfectly objective
if you have a quantum mechanical system
and you have two subsystems
and the system as a whole is in a what
we call a pure quantum mechanical state
it has a wave function
but the two subsystems are entangled
with each other then each one of those
subsystems has
an entropy given to us by john f neumann
he has a formula for it
and that's a hundred percent objective
that entropy has nothing to do with your
knowledge of the system it's because of
the quantum mechanical state
that the two entangled systems are in
and there are in between cases like the
boltzmann entropy where you have a
coarse graining
of all the possible ways that a
subsystem that subsystems can arrange
themselves
given the coarse graining boltzmann's
definition of entropy
is completely objective but your choice
of core screening in the first place is
subjective okay so it's a little bit of
a mixture
so i think that a lot of confusion
around the word entropy just comes in
because there's more than one definition
of it
and they all overlap an appropriate
regimes but they are actually telling
you very different things
anonymous says uh this is a long
question i edit down a little bit but
let me see if i can get to the essence
of it
with overwhelming likelihood new
particle physics would not have
good practical effects for humanity i
can imagine many ways the new physics
could let humanity destroy itself
but it's hard for me to come up with
plausible fine-tuning so that new
physics has a good effect on humanity
what do we do about this problem so i
think that you know the the spirit of
the question is
in the space of all new possible ways
that i could imagine physics we haven't
yet discovered it's easier
to imagine ways we could learn to hurt
ourselves or would hurt ourselves
inadvertently
versus ways that we could help ourselves
like you know free energy or something
like that
uh so what can we do about that well i
think that
it we should be honest i don't think
that you know you should hide the truth
in in any case but i actually think that
it depends what you mean by new physics
so you said new particle physics in
particular
i think that it is very very unlikely
that new particle physics will have
either good or bad effects for humanity
other than
learning more about the universe the
learning more about the universe is
definitely
an effect that new particle physics will
have and it's good
okay whereas technological applications
could be good or bad but i don't think
we're going to get any technological
applications out of new particle physics
in order to make new particle physics
you need a giant particle accelerator
these are not the things that you can
shrink down into the size of a phone or
a wristwatch or something like that or
even a tv set
so i don't think you should look to
particle physics for
applications technologically i think you
should look to
new particle physics for knowledge and
discovery
and that's an unalloyed good in my mind
vladimir yuff says if girdle's
incompleteness theorem can be applied to
physics
should scientists be able to figure out
which problems conceptually
do not have solutions so
i'm not sure that would what is meant
and
it's not just you vladimir this is a
common sort of
um tendency of people to say
well physicists try to understand
everything but girdles incompleteness
theorem says you can't so does that mean
there's
some physics problems that have no
solutions but i think
this is a case where you have to be a
little bit more precise
about exactly what girdle's
incompleteness theorem says
it says that if you have some formal
system right some axiomatic mathematical
system
um i'm gonna this is not rigorously what
it says but i can be this is casual
enough to get the right answer
you cannot the formal system cannot
prove its own consistency
and the way that you demonstrate that is
by saying that there are statements
which are um which basically say
i cannot be proven okay so you cannot
prove that if
you prove sorry if you did prove it then
it would be inconsistent because you've
proven something that says it's false
if you can't prove it then it's true but
you can't prove it so either there are
unprovable true statements or the system
is
inconsistent what in the world does that
have to do with physics
i have no idea i'm not sure what it's
supposed to do with physics that's not
how
physics works physics doesn't go around
starting with axioms and proving things
physics tries to construct uh models
that model the world right and then the
world works according to that model
we don't prove theorems that's just not
what we're about
so i'm not quite sure what the exact
limitation on physics is supposed to be
coming from girdle's theorem like
and you know maybe this is my limitation
maybe um you have some
more precise uh thing in mind but
no one who is worried about girdle's
theorem in physics has ever told me what
that precise worry is so i'm not
i don't think that there's any thing
that girdles theorem uh
should do to slow down physics and
trying to understand the universe as
well as it can
j m autobot probably a pseudonym says
i'm most fascinated with your ethics and
morality discussions although i
eat plants and animals i've been
thinking more about not eating animals
you've mentioned in the past that one
reason you believe it is moral to eat
animals is because animals do not have
the same experience that humans do
about missing the life they would have
experienced if they were not going to be
eaten
that is true but i struggle with the
fact that i know that i shortened the
experience of an animal whether it knew
about its life being shortened or not
i sometimes feel bad about that do you
have any thoughts about rationally
helping me think through this one
um i mean two two things to say
one is if you i'm not going to tell you
you should eat animals
if you feel bad about it then don't do
it okay like
you know i'm a moral constructivist i
think that our ideas of right or wrong
are are sort of ways that we systematize
our
inner moral intuitions and if your
intuition is against doing something
then you can't necessarily reason your
way out of it unless you have
other intuitions that say you should do
it and you're just trying to make them
compatible with each other so you know
there's nothing wrong with saying
i personally don't want to eat animals
that's a completely sensible
attitude to take um but to
talk about the specific reasoning that
you advanced here what you say
is you struggle with the fact that i
shortened the experience of an animal
whether it knew about his life being
shortened or not
so the implication seems to be that
having more animals having more
experiences
over the course of their lives would be
good okay
and there are absolutely moral
philosophies that say that is true
you can imagine a version of
utilitarianism under which that is true
where you literally
take somehow you imagine that you could
take the experience at each
moment in the course of an animal's
existence
uh and it's either good or bad hopefully
it's good then you add them up you do an
integral over all the experiences and
you try to maximize that number right
and i think that something quite like
what someone like peter singer
actually does right you imagine there's
some number
called the total utility of the world
which you get by adding up all the
goodness from every moment of time over
every individual
and maximize that number i personally
don't think that's a sensible moral
system
at all right i mean uh there and there's
various ways of arguing for that you
know there's
the this formal argument called the
repugnant conclusion
which argues that if you believe that
kind of utilitarianism
you should believe that it is always
better to have more people
no matter how miserable those people are
you can always
make the world better just by increasing
the number of miserable people
in the world and that doesn't seem
especially moral to me
i actually think that the whole project
is misguided i don't think there's a
number
called utility that you can get
by adding things up of different
experiences at different moments of time
in any way i don't know a way to add up
the experiences
that a cow has and the experiences that
i have how do you compare them
that just seems impossible not just
difficult not like a technical problem
but like
literally not a sensible thing to try to
do
so i wouldn't worry about the fact that
there was a life that you made shorter
than otherwise i mean human beings as a
species
have changed the the total
uh diversity of life on earth by a lot
in many bad ways
okay but how would it be different if we
really tried to maximize the number of
good experiences that living beings had
whatever it would be uh it would be very
very very very different than what we
are doing now
and i don't think that that's a sensible
thing to try to do
so i guess all i would say is think
through exactly
what it is that bothers you about
shortening that experience of that
animal and you may like i said at the
beginning you may come out saying yeah
that was bad i don't want to do that
and that's completely okay that's not
the way that i personally feel about it
brendan hall said when you arrived at
caltech you said you were given richard
feynman's old desk do you still have
this desk
do you feel bad when you spill coffee on
it and you get to keep it after you're
gone
um i do have the desk uh i do not feel
bad when i spill coffee on it i mean i
feel bad because i
don't like to spill coffee but they they
sort of uh
every i don't know 10 years or so they
refurbish the desk
you know they they polish it again so it
actually looks like much younger than it
than it is
and no i do not get to keep it after i'm
gone it will be given once i go
uh from caltech it will be given to uh
usually the joke that i get a lot of
mileage out of it goes to the most
senior theoretical physicist who is not
senior enough to get a brand new desk
um so i don't know who that will be
after me but someone else will get it
okay i'm gonna group together a bunch of
questions
uh on laplace's demon three questions on
laplace's demon
mike meyer says does laplace's demon
know the exact trajectory of our lives
from start to finish
stephen bernard says it seems to me that
if physics is deterministic as it
appears to be
then everything that exists must have
been encoded in the initial state of the
big bang
everything including all your books
contents library congress etc
this baffles me where did all this
content come from did it merely unfold
deterministically in the fullness of
time
and jesse rimler says i recently
listened to an episode of the bb show
bbc show in our time about pierce among
laplace
at one point one of the guests said
there have been numerous critiques of
the idea of laplace's demon
and the deterministic model of the
universe one example is if i roll a ball
up on the hill at just the right speed
so that it comes to the top and is still
and perfectly balanced
and then go into the future and try to
see what happened in the past i look
back and this thing is still on top of
the mountain
and then at some point it starts going
down the mountain there seems to be no
way to predict that moment from the
classical equations do you know what
he's getting at and does it present a
challenge to the concept of laplace's
demon
so laplace's demon to remind you those
of you who haven't heard of it is the
idea that in
classical newtonian mechanics it's
deterministic or at least seemingly
deterministic modular footnote we'll get
to in a second
so in the sense that you give me the
position of velocity
of every particle in the universe and
newton's laws of physics tell you what's
going to happen next okay so laplace
said imagine a vast intelligence
that knows the position and velocity of
every particle in the universe and knows
all the laws of physics
and has infinite calculational capacity
so to that vast intelligence the past
past present and future are equally
clear
it can figure out what will happen from
the present state
to the future so for mike myers question
is laplace's demon know the exact
trajectory of our lives from start to
finish
yes except that the losses demon doesn't
exist
it's crucially important by the way the
opossus demon doesn't exist
it's a thought experiment okay and
people get
in trouble taking it a little bit too
literally it really doesn't exist
to actually model the universe
effectively you would need a laplace's
demon that was basically as big as the
universe or at least as complicated as
the universe it's not something you can
it's very very misleading to think of it
as like a dude over there who knows a
lot of stuff
it's just not like that at all um
to jesse rimler's question yeah there
are
actual subtle things about
newton's laws of physics as newton wrote
them down
that make it not as deterministic as you
would think so the
specific example you're talking about is
called norton's dome
after john norton who is uh still around
by the way john norton is very active
philosopher of science at the university
of pittsburgh
and his example is is uh not that long
ago norton's dome
and i talk about it in fact in the
biggest ideas in the universe videos
that i mentioned
before if you want to read more about it
you can look it up there
and the idea is that yeah if you very
very carefully choose
your physical system then even newton's
laws are not deterministic
but the footnote there is that very very
careful is an exaggeration it is a set
of measure zero
of situations you can find yourself in
where
there's ambiguity in what newton's laws
say so
in the space of all initial conditions
for the universe
the fraction of possible initial
conditions that would run into this kind
of problem that you mention
is zero for almost all initial
conditions in the mathematically precise
sense of almost all
everything's perfectly deterministic so
as a practical matter
that's not a worry also laplace's demon
doesn't exist so it's not a worry in
that sense
either okay and then to steven's
question
so by the way you say it seems to me
that if physics is deterministic as it
appears to be
i'm not i wouldn't be that quick about
whether physics is deterministic or not
after all there is quantum mechanics
some versions of quantum mechanics are
deterministic in the old-fashioned way
like the pilot wave theories the the um
uh hidden variable theories we talked
about some versions of quantum mechanics
are just not deterministic like the
objective collapse models that i
mentioned
some versions of quantum mechanics like
many worlds are kind of deterministic
but kind of not
the wave function of the universe
evolves deterministically
but the individual branches do not okay
and i bring this up because it's
relevant to your question i mean you
have a good question that we
live in an extremely complicated
universe right now extremely specific
all the information in all the books
ever written or on all the hard drives
or whatever
was all that implicit in the early
universe well it depends
on your theory of quantum mechanics uh
we don't know whether things are
deterministic so if it's not
deterministic
if wave functions truly collapse
stochastically then no
then this information in um the
hard drives and the books was not there
it sort of came into existence
via these stochastic jumps
if there were hidden variables then yes
then all the information that determined
what is in
all the books everywhere was there in
the early universe
but you know you shouldn't let that
bother you like
where does this feeling come from that
there's not enough room for all that
information to be there
there could be plenty of room right
maybe an infamous room so
i wouldn't actually be bothered about
that and then in many worlds
um it's the most interesting case in
some sense because
the early universe could actually have
had very low information
content and evolved deterministically
but because the branches of the wave
function differentiate themselves over
time
individual branches could look like they
have a high information content
and so that's kind of interesting and
cool but um
in that sense the specific information
about what is
in the books on your branch of the wave
function was not there
uh because in the early universe there's
no such thing as your branch of the wave
function
in the early universe there was just one
big branch i hope that makes sense but
everything i said is true i'm not sure
if it's actually
very helpful okay and then to move on
from laplace's demon there's a
related set of questions about free will
and
man people love talking about free will
i don't love talking about free will
i've said this before i think the most
boring thing that we could be talking
about
but so what i did was we've got a whole
bunch of questions about free will i'm
going to group them together
i'm going to give a spiel about free
will and then maybe i will get
fewer questions about free will in the
future we'll see
but let me try let's try to read these
through and give them sensible answers
so mark bloor says in a block universe
if one can take a god's eye view one
will see that every conscious being is
unable to predict their future
and that many of them therefore conclude
that they have free will
but none of them does in the sense that
their future was set in stone when the
universe was created
so does a compatibilist have any choice
in taking their stance
donald tremblay says the podcast with
robert sapolsky was fascinating
inside the framework of physicalism
where we all agree on determinism
determinism
at the atomic level which we don't by
the way um
it seems to me that dennett and sapolsky
are at opposite ends of a continuum of
how much free will we have at the macro
level
i rewatched a discussion you had with
sam harris three years ago on this topic
at which time
i'd say you were near the den at end has
the needle moved for you over the past
couple years
chris mortlock says i will answer all
these questions so i want to get them on
the table first chris mortlock says
i'm interested in your opinion on
individuals who commit evil acts and
their free will or human accountability
in engaging in such abhorrent activities
my first thought is to have hatred for
these people being the worst of the
worst
but i also find myself stuck with an
intermoral dilemma when i start to
contemplate that these individuals are
only undertaking such acts
due to some kind of physical or chemical
interactions in their brain or basic
particle interactions outside of their
control
michael lacey says at the end of your
podcast on rationality with julia
galliff
she talks about self-deception as being
a bad alternative for making oneself
feel better as someone who doesn't
believe in libertarian free will
do you think it's okay to alleviate
regret with the thought that our actions
are ultimately the result of physical
laws
or as a compatibilist do you think that
it is as much of a cop-out as
self-deception daniela cortese says
you said that you don't worry whether
libertarian free will could be described
mathematically because you don't believe
in it
but isn't it important to understand
regardless if there
are phenomena that can't be expressed
mathematically even in principle
isn't this a problem for a complete and
sound understanding of the foundations
of the universe
and finally flying waffle probably also
a pseudonym says
isn't it paradoxical that atoms don't
experience
choice i.e they just blindly follow the
fundamental laws of particle physics
yet at the macro level of living
organisms brains have evolved in order
to capture and model their environment
in terms of probability distributions as
a way to guide apparent choices
okay that's a lot of questions so let me
just lay out how i think about this very
quickly
um so there are these three different
stances
in free will thought roughly speaking
one is
libertarian free will which is the idea
there's something special about human
beings we have a special spirit
an ability to sort of overcome um
the laws of physics right we are a law
unto ourselves
i don't believe that scientists
generally don't believe that let's put
libertarian free will aside for the
moment
the other two options are either your
compatibilist about free will
or you're an incompatibilist okay
sometimes
incompatibleists describe themselves as
hard determinists
but that's just a mistake that's just
wrong
because whether your compatibilist or
incompatibilist has
nothing at all to do with whether the
laws of physics are deterministic i
cannot
possibly emphasize this enough what
matters is that there are laws
whether those laws are deterministic or
not makes zero difference to whether
you're a compatibilist or an
incompatibilist you both believe that
there are laws
okay whether you believe the fundamental
laws are a pilot wave theory of quantum
mechanics or a spontaneous collapse
theory of quantum mechanics
one of which is deterministic and one of
which is not who cares
that doesn't affect whether you're a
compatibilist or not so don't
label yourself a hard determinist that
is not the point you would still be
anti-free will
if you're incompatibilist even if the
grw theory of quantum mechanics or
penrose's theory turns out to be correct
even if determinism is not there it's
the fact that there are laws that
matters
okay the compatibilist what are you
compatible about
you're saying that the belief in free
will that describing human beings
as agents that make decisions that make
choices
is compatible with human beings being
made of
either neurons or elementary particles
or whatever you want that obey the laws
of physics
a compatibilist says you can describe
the world in different ways
that are compatible with each other even
though they use very different
vocabularies
one way of describing the world is sort
of at the microscopic level where you're
made of a bunch of particles
they're obeying the laws of physics
whatever those laws are deterministic or
indeterministic
and there's no free will there you know
free will does not enter the lagrangian
for the standard model of particle
physics okay
no one thinks it does and then there's
another level there's a biological level
and then there's finally a human level
where you have
people okay and the compatibility says
people make choices this doesn't seem
like a very controversial thing to say
but apparently it is so here's one way
of thinking about it
um alice and bob are in a car
alice is driving bob is navigating with
his uh
google maps and they're looking for a
restaurant and bob
says oh turn left up here at this
intersection the restaurant will be
right there
uh once we turn left alice turns left
and there's no restaurant there and
alice says
what's going on you told me to turn left
i turned left because you told me to
turn left
and bob says yeah no i knew the
restaurant wasn't there but the laws of
physics
said that that would be what i would say
and that's what you would do so i'm not
really to blame for anything that
happened
nobody in their right mind talks that
way right
everyone in the world who is not crazy
says
alice made a choice to turn left why
because bob told her to turn left and
she trusted that bob was going to give
her the correct information
right bob made a choice to tell alice
something
why well i don't know there's something
perverse in bob's mind that made him
you know play a little game or something
like that literally nobody
refuses to talk that way in the real
world now there are people who pretend
to not talk that way they will say oh no
alice and bob didn't make any choices
but when it comes right down to it these
people are constantly trying to convince
you
to choose to not believe in free will so
you can't act that way you can't live in
the world
because it's not a good description of
the world at the human level
to act as if human beings don't make
choices
the reason why compatibilists think that
it's sensible to talk about human beings
as
agents that make choices is because
that's the best
theory we have of people
and it literally is everyone's theory
there's no one who doesn't have that
theory because it works it's it's true
and you know i did the podcast with sam
harris a long time ago
um you know so to be this is a little
frustration that comes out uh from me
and i will i will
vent my frustration here and it's not
just sam harris it's many other people
i don't think i have ever met a
incompatibilist
who could correctly describe to me what
compatibilists think
there there's only straw compatibilists
live
in the mind of incompatibilists and uh
the incompatibilists seem to think that
if they
you know really if you really believe in
the laws of physics they can construct a
logical cage to get you to admit
that we're made of particles that obey
the laws of physics but i admit that
and this the discussion with sam was
incredibly frustrating because that's
what he was trying
to do you know he was trying to say like
okay like if i knew all of the laws and
all the particles and i was laplace's
demon
and you know he's pushing against an
open door i admit all that
if you describe the universe as
microscopically in the laws of physics
then it obeys the laws of physics and
there's no free will there that's just
not
the point in the point of view of a
compatibilist
and so and this is why it's very
important to realize that apostle's
demon doesn't exist
and none of us is anywhere close to
laplace's demon now
there are interesting questions to talk
about
that are not that question the
interesting questions are and
this gets into some of the questions
here what about the edge cases where it
becomes
less and less useful to describe people
as agents making choices
based on good reasons right like what if
you are a drug addict or you have some
brain damage or something like that and
you're just you're under a compulsion
that forces you to do something
and then i would say indeed it becomes
less and less useful to describe that
person
as an agent making rational choices and
we do we don't we don't describe those
people
as as robustly as agents making rational
choices so
that discussion the practical level
discussion about
how to treat people um
who suffer in different ways from an
inability to be a completely
rational agent which we all do none of
us are completely rational like there
are degrees of it
so you know how do you deal with that in
the real world that's an interesting
discussion to have
but this whether or not to label it free
will discussion is to me the most boring
thing in the world because there aren't
people who don't talk about other people
as choice makers in my mind and if you
are someone who believes in the laws of
physics deep down
but you say but i will of course in my
everyday life i will talk about people
making choices
then there's a word for what you are
it's called compatibilism that's
that's what you are all right so let me
with that in mind
let me address some of these specific
questions uh mark bloor says
does a compatibilist have any choice in
being a compatibilist given that it's
baked into the laws of physics
well if you're describing the world
at the microscopic level with including
the position and velocity of every
particle or the entire wave function of
the universe
then no the choi the idea of a choice
doesn't enter into that picture of the
universe but
as previously mentioned nobody does that
nor will anybody ever do that
what we actually do is describe people
incompletely
with incomplete information with
incomplete knowledge of the laws that
make them do their thing
as agents making choices and at that
level of description
yes compatibilists do have choices in
taking their stances
to donald tremblay's questions um have i
moved
the needle move for me over the past
couple years nope
i've you know i'm willing to move my
needle like free will again it's not my
favorite topic i
don't care about it people keep talking
to me about it
and so i'm not that wedded to my
position but certainly i've not heard
anything to make me change my position
in the last couple years
chris mortlock wanted to know how should
you feel about
people who commit evil acts uh and their
free will and human accountability and
engaging in abhorrent activities
well here's where it becomes delicate it
depends on the person right
if you have good reason to believe
there's a sense in which
the person didn't have a choice if they
were you know addicted or controlled or
did were mentally incapable of doing
something else
then i the feeling i would feel for them
is more feeling sorry for them
if you think that the best description
we have this person is as someone who
could have done otherwise
given what we know about them not given
all the laws of physics in the
microscopic state of the universe
because you don't have that
given what we know about them could they
have done otherwise rationally
then you can be angry at them i think
that's perfectly legitimate i'm angry at
people all the time i'm angry at myself
all the time
michael lacy said um do i think it's
okay to alleviate regret with the
thought that our actions are ultimately
a result of physical laws
no i think that is a cop-out that's
that's just like self-deception because
the the fact that you know again it just
doesn't matter that the that the actions
are ultimately the result of physical
laws
i don't know my micro state that's no
help psychologically
daniela cortese said uh
if there are phenomena about can
libertarian free will be described
mathematically
so i'm not exactly sure what i said so
you began the question saying you said
that you don't worry whether libertarian
free will could be described
mathematically because i don't believe
in it
um there's a sense in which anything
can be described mathematically you know
even if
a sequence of numbers is completely
random the statement that it's
completely random
is a mathematical statement right so
um i do think that there would be a way
to describe even libertarian free will
mathematically i think what i what i
would mean
about i don't know what i was saying
when you were listening to me so maybe i
just said it badly or sloppily but
i think that the point is that
libertarians don't think that there are
laws that give you in some useful way
for knowledge of how people are going to
behave even
at the level of microphysics so a um
the incompatibilist says yeah there are
laws that you know the laws of physics
they tell you how people are going to
behave
the compatibilist says the laws of
physics tell you how people are going to
behave if you have
the microstate of the whole universe in
at your disposal but you don't
uh at the human level there are at best
vague tendencies you know you can
predict probabilistically what people
are going to do
but it's not that sort of microscopic
precision that you have
whereas a libertarian would say nope
there's just nothing you can say except
maybe
wait for it to happen and then
categorize everything mathematically
as a probability distribution or as a
frequency for different things happening
so yeah i think i i don't know whether
libertarian free will even makes sense
that's the more honest thing that i
could say but if it did make sense then
after the fact you could certainly
summarize what people actually did
that's something that's always possible
finally for flying waffles uh question
isn't it interesting that brains have
evolved in order to capture and model
their environment in terms of
probability distributions even though
atoms don't
you know i don't think it's paradoxical
at all
atoms don't have a lot of internal
memory
right atoms cannot uh process
information in any interesting way
atoms just don't have a lot of registers
once you have a tremendous num
individual atoms by which i mean brains
are collections of many many many atoms
and then you have
different arrangements you can put those
atoms in that correspond to
different images of the outside world so
because those images are
incomplete because we have incomplete
information it makes perfect sense to me
that we model our environment as
probability distributions because we
don't know when we will never know
uh everything there is to know about the
microstate of the universe
okay that's enough for free will for the
moment anyway we'll see what happens
next time uh
moving on gregory kuznek says dean
bonamano argue that in the absence of
direct empirical evidence for closed
time-like curves we should trust our
presentest
this seems to parallel the argument
against many worlds even if we never
observe any ctcs
shouldn't the fact that their existence
is predicted by known solutions to
einstein's well-tested equation
give us high credence in eternalism so i
don't actually
think i mean i am an eternalist myself
but i don't think that this
parallel actually works that you're
suggesting greg because
the point is that in many worlds the
prediction of the schrodinger equation
is that our world will actually branch
that there will be branching in the
future just because tiny quantum systems
become entangled with their environments
whereas someone like dean would say look
when you have space
time einstein's equation uh
seems to govern our space time pretty
well seems to apply to our space time
it also has other solutions but
classically at least there is only one
universe
the fact that there's an equation that
has other solutions that are not like
our universe doesn't matter
if it's not our universe so these other
solutions with close time like curves
uh whether it's from tipler's uh
cylinder
or girdles universe or the wormholes or
god's cosmic strings
as long as they're not our universe that
doesn't actually give us any argument
against
um presentism would be would be the
argument
pete catullus says this is a long
question but i think i think it's worth
it i don't know how to shorten it it's a
cute story
i recently read a story about a man
named joseph fertenbach who in
1627 supposedly performed an experiment
designed to show that the earth rotates
about its axis
fertenbach fired a cannon straight up
into the air and stood calmly by the
muzzle
as the cannonball went up into the air
he expected the motion of the rotating
earth to cause the ball to hit the
ground
some distance to the west of his
position as he told onlookers if he was
incorrect
the ball would instead come down on his
head killing him
the story goes that the cannonball did
in fact hit the ground and form a small
crater to the west
of the cannon not killing him presumably
an ama an amusing story but it did prove
did it prove the motion of the earth or
was fertenbach just
lucky unless my understanding of physics
is way off wouldn't a cannonball fire in
a perfectly perpendicular direction to
the surface of the earth
be expected to land in the same spot
from which it is fired
barring other forces such as wind so
pete i have never heard the story before
so i don't know the details of whether
or not ferdibach was just lucky but i
think you're right in the physics
analysis here
you know there's an old saying there are
many wrong ways to get the right answer
and even though the earth is rotating
uh this particular analysis by
pertinbach does not seem to be
correct like you say if the canon and
the cannonball and everything else is
moving along with the surface of the
earth
then what you would expect is when you
fire the cannonball up it will come
straight down in fact
this is that the kind of reasoning that
led galileo to invent galilean
relativity
uh around the same time in the early
1600s in fact
galileo what he talks about i forget
whether he actually did this or not
but he talks about an analogous
experiment on a ship
so you go on a ship and then you climb
all the way up to the mast
and you can drop a cannonball or
something lighter probably don't want to
drop a cannonball onto the ship but
anyway you drop a ball
straight down and galileo's point was
again i don't know whether he did it or
not but
if the ship is stationary then you
should
expect the ball to fall straight down if
the ship
is moving at a constant velocity you
will also
expect the ball to fall straight down
because the ship and the ball are moving
with each other
and there's no absolute frame of
reference with respect to judge your
velocity it's only relative that's the
invention of
relativity in some very real sense
and galileo is right and in fact galio
used this as an argument that it's okay
to think that the earth is rotating
you wouldn't notice if the earth is
rotating because all the physical
experiments you do here on earth
would have the same answers as if it
weren't rotating because of relativity
for exactly that reason so i don't know
what fertin box story was
but again you can reason your way into
the right answer for wrong reasons in
fact galileo did this galileo
had a whole explanation for the tides
that uh was completely wrong and but he
used that as evidence that the earth was
rotating so you know there you go a lot
of people had wrong
reasons to get the correct answer in
that case
johnny says in your conversation with
julia galif you point out that most
people don't revisit or question their
beliefs often enough
if you turn a critical eye upon yourself
are you also guilty of this
uh sure probably you know i mean i have
a whole bunch of beliefs and i like my
beliefs
and they fit in together into a system
that reinforces itself and of course one
should always be critical of
one's beliefs but it's hard to do so
it's on the other hand
easy to say that i or anyone else should
be critical
of our own beliefs but very hard to say
which ones we should be
critical of you know this is a common
but very bad argument
when you say something that is true and
your opponent says
well do you think you're always right do
you think you should be doubtful of your
results sometimes and you say yeah no
i'm not always right i should be
doubtful my results sometimes
and they say well okay you should be
doubtful of it this time that doesn't
follow
logically like maybe this particular
time you're pretty darn confident
so it's easy to say you should be
critical of your own beliefs it's harder
to know which of your beliefs are the
ones that might turn out to be wrong
we should all try though right this is
an aspirational kind of thing we should
try to be
good bayesians give credences to the
things that we think are unlikely but
still
possible jeff b says
i once had a thought about the universe
and i'm wondering whether it holds any
truth
the idea is that all possible states of
the universe coexist
and it is merely the records of other
states that give the illusion of time
so this is almost the right point of
view for an eternalist to believe
in fact the reason why i like this
question uh is because it is giving
voice to the point of view that saint
augustine
had back in i don't know the third
century or whatever it was
uh fourth century maybe when augustine
in his confessions has a famous
discussion of the nature of time
and one of his quotes he's a very
quotable guy is
the past is present memory the idea
being that in his
ontology the past exists in the present
moment
in the form of our records of what the
past actually held
now he didn't know about classical
mechanics or laplace's demon
these days we can a little bit be a
little bit more quantitative and
rigorous about it
the entire information is conserved from
moment to moment to the extent
the laws of physics are deterministic so
in some sense the past is contained in
the present moment
the one part of your proposal that i
would um
change is you say all possible states of
the universe
coexist and this is a very typical
issue that comes up when you try to be a
good eternalist the eternalist is
someone who believes that
every moment of time is equally real
because
at any one moment you and i and everyone
else are embedded
in that moment we have a way of talking
about the world that is
loaded temporally speaking right with
respect to
time so what you should say as a good
eternalist is
all moments of time are equally real
what is very tempting to say but is
wrong is
all moments of time are equally real now
or coexisting or simultaneously real or
real at the same time you're giving
different moments of time a little bit
of existence at the same time which is a
contradiction that's not what is
going on so i sort of halfway agree with
your proposal there jeff
farron christou says i just listened to
your solo mindscape episode on entropic
gravity from september 2019
and would like to know what your
thoughts are now about holography in
general
and on implications for locality if
information is randomly encoded on the
holographic boundary as i've heard
suskind postulate
well you know so by the way if you're
not gone through the whole um
back catalog there is an episode with
suskin that you can listen to and hear
his own
points of view of this my points of view
my
perspective hasn't changed a lot i
have the following vague idea and this
this is so here's something where i have
an idea and it could be completely wrong
so my belief would change rapidly if if
we learned more um we had this idea of
holography suskind and the tuft and
others
john preschool and others sort of worked
toward this idea in the 1990s trying to
understand black holes
and the idea that black holes have an
entropy can be used to argue that
the information in a black hole can be
thought of as
living on the horizon of the black hole
or near the horizon of the black hole
rather than living
inside the volume of the black hole that
was later sharpened to black hole
complementarity
which says that it depends on what
observer you're talking about to an
observer that falls inside
the information is scattered through the
volume to an information to an observer
outside the information
looks like it's located on the boundary
and also it became
much sharper in the context of the ads
cft correspondence from juan maldasena
muldacena points out that there is the
specific example
of an anti-dissider cosmology where
there is a boundary
and the boundary looks like a space time
of one less dimension
and in fact in certain special cases
there's a theory of physics on the
boundary that is
the same as equivalent to a theory of
quantum gravity in the bulk
uh that's the ads cft correspondence and
so that's holography because the
boundary theory which is supposed to be
equivalent to the bulk theory
lives in one lower dimension so
my feeling i said i had a feeling here
an idea that might or may not be right
my feeling is that ads cft has misled us
a little bit because adscft is a
wonderful example of duality of
holography
of a working model of quantum gravity
etc it's also not the real world we
don't live in anti-descender space
and so and it's also hard and it's
unclear whether or not it's hard because
it's it's intrinsically hard or we human
beings aren't very good at it but it's
hard
in ads cft to
use the purported duality between the
boundary and the bulk
to really talk about physics that goes
on on very small scales inside
the bulk it's easy to talk about big
cosmological questions it's hard to talk
about small scale questions even though
many people think it's in principle
possible um
so i think that the misleadingness it's
not that ads cft is
edsc if he's wrong in any way but
that the way that holography might work
in the real world will be sufficiently
different
i'm guessing than ads cft
that focusing on ads cft is not helping
us as much as we would like it to it's
helping us some it's worth doing i think
it's great
all in favor of it but i think other
kinds of thought processes are going to
be needed
to really get holography to work in the
real world in local conditions
in black holes or whatever so i don't
think our universe has
something quite as simple and direct and
tangible as a holographic boundary
that we would have if we lived in ads i
think it's going to be more subtle than
that
i don't know what it's going to be so
it's easy for me to say but we'll have
to wait and see
murray dunn says do we know with any
certainty that the net charge or angular
momentum of the universe is zero
well no we know very few things with uh
any certainty
about the universe we should always be
humble about those things the statement
we can make is
given the laws of physics as we
understand them in a
closed universe in the universe where
space
is a closed manifold either a sphere or
a torus or whatever
then the net charge and angular momentum
and even the net energy will be zero
that's just a topological fact okay um
you can't the field lines can't go
anywhere right like if you have an
electric charge
its electrical field lines stretch out
to infinity but if you live on a taurus
or a sphere
infinity comes back on itself and those
field lines have to come back and go
somewhere and they can't
unless the net charge is zero if you
think about a positive charge at the
north pole of a sphere
if you don't want to have charges
anywhere else you're going to need to
have a negative charge at the south pole
of the sphere to make everything
work out consistently so but what we
don't know
is whether or not the universe is closed
maybe the universe is open if the
universe is open
then we can certainly have a net charge
or net angular momentum no problem
thomas prunty says in this week's solo
podcast you did a lot of talking about
particles environment diagrams clouds of
virtual particles etc
essentially nothing about fields in the
past you've emphasized fields as being
more fundamental
what gives you know i actually when i
was planning out that solo podcast i
thought about
talking in terms of fields but then i i
had the thought that
number one it'd be a lot more uh talk
and number two would be distracting from
what i was trying to talk about
i would basically be saying the same
things but with an extra 20 minute
digression
on why it's really fields okay but
that's not the point the point was to
talk about
um the particular experimental
results that we were trying to explain
here so
what i try to say is fields are more
fundamental you're right
in quantum field theory but there's a
good reason why we call it particle
physics
in the regime where you have tiny
vibrations in those fields when you
observe them
they look like particles and when you
calculate
processes using feynman diagrams you're
using a very
particle-based language and that's fine
fields are more fundamental but when the
particle
language is appropriate it's appropriate
and
there's no more time and particle
language is appropriate than when you're
doing particle physics and doing
scattering experiments
and calculating findment diagrams so you
could translate everything that i said
there
into talk about fields and what i
decided was that for the purposes of
that
uh discussion it wasn't adding anything
to the discussion to sort of
restate exactly the same thing in the
field language there's a reason why
particle physicists use finding diagrams
all the time they're really convenient
for that kind of analysis
anonymous says do you have any advice
for dealing with a spouse or other
faculty family member
i almost said faculty member hopefully
you have
people in your family who are not
faculty members but do you have any
advice for dealing with a spouse or
other family member
that you love dearly but who believes
wholeheartedly in things like astrology
esp new age spirit spiritualism cloaked
in science things like that
um short answer is no uh it depends on
the family member like different people
are going to be
different you know there are a couple of
things i do think are true and are worth
keeping in mind
in this kind of situation one is some
people are not going to be reasoned out
of their beliefs and don't try
if you think that there's going to be
someone who just isn't open
to thinking about whatever their set of
beliefs are then you know
you're not under any obligation to bang
your head against the wall and try to
convince them if you know it's not going
to work ahead of time
there are other people who will have
such beliefs but are but are
open-minded about them you know they
think that they have reasoned themselves
into those beliefs in a rational way and
are open to changing their minds
and are and want to engage in discussion
about it then do that
so my point is it depends on that
individual
um it also depends on you how important
is this to you that someone has the same
set of beliefs about these things
as you do and i have no judgment one way
or the other like i
totally get it if uh you care about
someone and love them and you're they're
a member of your family
and they have incompatible beliefs with
you and you say you know what that's
okay they have different beliefs i'm
just gonna roll with that we love them
for other reasons that's okay
it's also okay to say these particular
beliefs are so
important to me that i can't let it go
right and you have to pick and choose
where your values lie there the final
thing is
uh there are people who might be
persuadable or at least
interested in talking about it but don't
want to be beaten over the head
don't want to be felt to be irrational
or stupid
right very often if your actual
interest is not in winning some debate
but in changing someone's mind or
opening them up to new possibilities
the strategy is not to bring out your
biggest debating guns
right the strategy is not to be as
rational and evidence-based as you can
the strategy is to by example
show them that they can get rid of those
beliefs
and still lead a happy fulfilling life
right
very often this goes back to like week
one of the mindscape podcast where i
interviewed anthony penn
who is an atheist theologian uh who's
also
black and he's interested in why black
people are not more atheist
and he made the point that you know
atheism doesn't make
an a good case empirically in the real
world
this is not a necessary uh condition but
actual atheists
here and now often just don't make a
good case for why black people would be
equally as fulfilled
socially and culturally outside the
church as they are inside of it
right so a lot of times these people
reason themselves into these beliefs or
reasons that are other than perfectly
rational
and it's okay to reason them out of them
for reasons that are other than
perfectly rational or maybe they're
rational like from a different angle
right like what makes me happier that's
a perfectly rational
thing to have so think about it
holistically think about why they
believe it
think about whether they are so devoted
to it that they might change their mind
or even if they are open to talking
about it at all there's no cut and dried
answer ahead of time
george attensoff says in your book
something deeply hidden you mentioned
that the wave function of a particle
spreads out in space in a roughly
spherical fashion
what would be the reason for roughly why
not perfectly spherical
well it depends on the details of the
initial condition for the particle so
typically what i'm talking about there
is you know the decay of a nucleus that
emits a particle you know a beta decay
you emit electron
alpha decay you emit a hydrogen atom
sorry a helium
nucleus and these are things that have
wave functions and they will
spread out roughly spherically but maybe
not perfectly spherically because in
fact there will be
um a specific wave function that is
whatever is the schrodinger
equations solution given the initial
conditions
as the most obvious example if the
nucleus itself
that you started with was spinning then
it's not spherically symmetric
right a spinning nucleus has an axis
around which it's spinning
and so it might emit with a wave
function that's either bigger or smaller
perpendicular to that axis versus
parallel to that axis
so it's just a matter of uh you know
where you start
uh that tells you where you end up chris
fotosh
says regarding dark matter dark energy
new particles the graviton
in your view where do they fit into the
standard model are they part of the
current model
as new rows or columns well you've given
examples here
uh dark matter dark energy new particles
the graviton these are four very
different examples
they all have very different stories to
tell about them dark energy is most
likely not a particle
it's most likely just the cosmological
constant so it's not in the standard
model at all it's just a
parameter in the laws of physics easy to
add
if it is not a cosmological concept if
it's dynamical then it could be a new
particle but a very very very very
light particle that interacts very very
weakly with ordinary matter
dark matter likewise it probably is a
new particle it interacts very weakly
with ordinary matter or he would have
found it before
so i think that in some sense um
there's a good way of thinking about
this and this might also be true for
the muon anomalies that we talked about
in the last solo podcast
even if we extend the standard model
even if we find
new things dark matter particles dark
energy particles or whatever
fields um it might turn out to be the
case that what we currently call the
standard model
still has a status as a coherent sort of
part
of the universe right there's what we
now call the standard model
and we'll extend it but we'll still say
that this part was the standard model
and then we have new things
right maybe supersymmetric particles or
excitations and extra dimensions or
relics of grand unification but the
standard model will still be the
standard model
maybe so what i'm saying is it's not
clear until we actually do it
whether or not we will end up uh
re-labeling the standard model to
include
whatever new things we find or we'll
keep the current standard model and just
say the standard model is not all
of what we know in particle physics the
graviton is a special case because
we know that gravity exists we know that
gravitons exist even though we've never
found them
as long as you think that there is
gravity and there's quantum mechanics
something like the graviton will exist
but technically speaking it's not in
standard model so
whatever it's in the core theory that's
why frank wiltjack
labeled came up with this label the core
theory because gravity exists you should
include it so that's
gravity plus the standard model is the
core theory
adriana sasserman says in a scenario
where there are no restrictions for
civilians to go to the international
space station would you consider going
uh i'd consider it you know i wouldn't
be driven i wouldn't be like uh you know
hyper passionate about it to be honest
like it'd be fun it'd be cool
being out in space sounds like an
awesome thing at the same time
uh in the current level of technology
it's it is to be
fair super dangerous flying into space
super dangerous we have accidents
at quite a high rate compared to what
you would really like
and as cool as it would be going into
space
i have a lot of cool things i still want
to do here on earth so
you have to balance that right you have
to say well what is the risk that you
would be
willing to take and you know i think
there are other people
in the world who would get more out of
going into space than i would
honestly like again i have plenty of
things i want to do
here on earth so even though i do think
it would be cool i would not
uh do everything i can to force my way
to the front of the line how about that
okay i'm going to group two questions
together here because they're both about
the
past hypothesis of low entropy in the
early universe
lothian 53 says if the early universe
was high entropy
could it have had inflation or the
expansion of the universe
and if we had these wouldn't matter
still clump due to gravity and then
collapse into suns providing the energy
to power life
steve pilling says you seemed a bit
doubtful about brian green's paper
suggesting that gravity was switched off
in the early formation of the universe
to account for the low entropy
this explanation seems to be quite
plausible to me
and if the higgs field was switched off
for example this would presumably have
such an effect
because the particles would not gain
mass from the higgs mechanism
so both of these have to do with what we
call the past hypothesis
in the foundations of statistical
mechanics we know the entropy is
increasing
in order to get that to have to happen
under rules of physics that are
individually fundamentally time
reversible
we need to assume an imbalance in the
initial versus the final conditions of
the universe we need to assume the early
universe had low entropy that's what the
past hypothesis
is supposed to say so the first question
from lothian 53 is
well what if it were high entropy
couldn't you and you know in the back of
one's mind you'd think well couldn't you
have high entropy but still have the
same
story of inflation and expansion and
clumping etc
and so no the answer is no it depends on
what you mean
by high entropy truly high entropy
remember what we're talking about here
is a system that has gravity
okay so a system where space-time is
curved and space-time has dynamics
that's important part of the story
i think a lot of people get confused
when they talk about gravity and entropy
and cosmology by imagining we can
keep the space time fixed and mess
around with what the matter is doing and
call that
you know a new situation but they're
coupled to each other the gravity
the curvature of space-time and what the
matter are doing both matter
as it were so the
there's a result that a paper that i
wrote with
aidan chatwin davis where we showed that
what you mean by high entropy
in a universe with a positive
cosmological constant is
empty space de sitter space it's so not
anti-dissider space which is a an empty
universe with a negative cosmos constant
but d
center space is an empty universe with a
positive cosmological constant um
and so we were not the first to suggest
this but we actually were able to prove
it under some assumptions i just said
an hour ago that you don't prove things
but here is an example a counter example
because we actually proved a little
result
where here are your assumptions and we
showed that there's an equivalence
between what is called the cosmic no
hair theorem
which says that in the presence of a
positive vacuum energy the universe will
just empty out
and you'll be left with nothing but
empty space to sitter space
expanding forever and the second law of
thermodynamics which says that entropy
continues to increase eventually you hit
thermal equilibrium
increasing entropy can be thought of as
this approach
to empty space so by hypothesis if you
say
if the early universe was high entropy
it would be empty space it would not be
hot and dense and rapidly expanding
that's not what it would be
okay so if you start with high entropy
then you're just in empty space and you
stay there forever so you do not
collapse into stars or
gravity or anything like that there's
nothing around to do any of that
collapsing and to steve's question so
brian greene and his
collaborators had a paper which said the
following thing again
if you imagine that you could separate
out
what gravity was doing from what matter
is doing
then there's a sense in which the early
universe if you could ignore
gravity looks like it's high entropy
that is to say the temperature profile
of the early universe the
the photons the spectrum that we get
from the cosmic microwave background
if it weren't for gravity the spectrum
looks like a black body
that's a high entropy situation so many
people have pointed this out
but it the early universe looks weird
in the absence of some theoretical
understanding because
the gravitational situation is very very
orderly and low entropy
given that the matter situation is very
disorderly in high entropy okay
now gravity is much more important in
this situation so
overall it's very very low entropy but
that's a that's a fact that we can think
about trying to take advantage of so
brian's paper tries to take advantage of
that by saying well
maybe you turn off gravity in the early
universe the matter degrees of freedom
equilibrate they go to their maximum
entropy state where it looks like a
black body
then there is separately some some
process
magic that turns on gravity okay it's
not really magic it's a scalar field or
something like that
okay here's why that doesn't work so one
thing sorry footnote
this is nothing to do with the higgs
mechanism okay gravity has nothing to do
with the higgs mechanism
gravity exists whether particles have
mass or don't gravity exists for photons
photons have mass but they used to
dominate the energy of the universe okay
massiveness of particles is affected by
the higgs mechanism
completely different than gravity
gravity is affected by newton's constant
so when you turn off gravity in the
early universe what you're saying is
newton's constant was zero newton's
constant of gravity in the early
universe
the reason why i don't think that solves
the problem is it's not robust
um i mean it's just equivalent to saying
the early universe was in a very very
very special early state
and the reason you know that is if you
took our universe today and you let it
collapse rather than expand
even if gravity turned off in the early
universe it wouldn't smooth out while
it's collapsing
right they cheat in other words
by putting the universe into a very very
special initial condition
and you can show that by just reversing
the problem
and so if you really want to explain
the robustly and without cheating the
low entropy of the early universe
you need to come up with a story
that works both directions in time a
story that you can say well you give me
conditions at one moment of time i will
use the laws of physics to evolve it
forward and backward
and eventually i would get the same
answer that's what jennifer chen and i
tried to do in our 2004 paper
it's becoming like it's creeping up
people are beginning to catch on
uh that this is a good thing to try to
do julian barber and his um
collaborators are the most famous
example of people who are trying to
use that kind of technique james
cantrell
says with so much noise out there in the
information sphere how does someone
who's not terribly smart
go about making a smart choice and
choosing what expertise to latch onto
so james i refuse to believe that any
patreon supporters of the mindscape
podcast are not terribly smart you're
obviously making good decisions in your
life but
taking it that you must not be talking
about yourself but someone else
this is a good question i mean let's say
forget about being smart being smart is
not the point but let's say expertise
if you don't have expertise in a certain
area which all of us
lack expertise in some areas how do you
go about choosing what experts to
believe
there's a lot of purported experts out
there and they say
incompatible things you know this came
up a little bit in my podcast with julia
galiff
um i really liked that podcast because
it made me think after the fact about
what we talked about a lot
and julia you know one of the questions
i asked her was
you want to be a good bayesian you want
to start with some credences on
different possibilities
update them on evidence but that
starting point is tricky
and especially when you're in a
situation where you're not an
expert and you are like you said in your
question like you have different voices
coming in and saying different things
so if if you hear what might be a
crackpot
or what might be a brilliant idea and
you don't know
you're not an expert how do you judge
right and so
julia actually after the podcast she
went on twitter and she
sort of you know she gave an answer in
real time but then you know
thought through it more and went on
twitter and tried to explain more
and you know she offered some tentative
suggestions for how you would judge the
credibility of a source
that was making you know outrageous
claims are they a genius or are they
just a crackpot
and she got some pushback from people
who said well
all of your criteria are about the
person making the claim
not the claim itself and she responded
like
yes because what i'm saying is i by
hypothesis i am not an expert
in judging the claims themselves all i
have to go on
is the person making the claim i think
that's perfectly okay that will be
true in some cases where you you just
don't personally have the expertise to
judge the claims
for themselves you have to think to
yourself is the person making this claim
credible in my mind
and there are a number of things that go
into that obviously do they have a track
record right i mean have they made
other claims in this area that have
panned out
are they recognized as an expert uh have
they
whatever it takes written papers written
books made predictions you know whatever
it takes to say yes they're not just
selling you a line of goods they
know something about this but you know
there are people who do have a track
record who then go crazy right
that that's something you also have to
take in mind i think the more
interesting criterion or or piece of
information you can use to evaluate this
question is
when they're making their claims
how do they relate those claims to other
claims
in particular how do the how does the
person making this claim
talk about the arguments against
their claim so if a person says you know
here's my claim people will tell you i'm
wrong
but they are pawns of the establishment
and they're out to get me
and they're dumb and whatever it is
then i'm actually much less likely to
take them seriously
if people say here are arguments why i
might be wrong
and they're good arguments i get it i
understand why you would believe it
i am now going to go through and tell
you why none of these arguments are
persuasive
in this case that's much more convincing
to me
a person who demonstrates that they
appreciate why they might be wrong
is much more likely in my mind to be
right at the end of the day
and there's other things you can think
about uh doing but that kind of thing
you know you have to
you have to um develop your [ __ ]
detector i mean
carl sagan had a baloney detection kit
that you know he tried to go through but
there's no algorithm
right you have to sort of get good at
recognizing what kinds of people are
credible
in this kind of game it's hard and you
will make mistakes we all do i do
jim murphy says i've often heard certain
types of people say that humanity
as a whole is sick or that we have
abandoned our natural way of being
i think this is probably a bit strong
but we do seem to have a very
anthropocentric way of thinking
do you think that we need to work as a
species on viewing ourselves
less centrally um so i think this is a
good question to sort of raise and
contemplate but i'm not sure i can give
you a very
persuasive simple answer because i mean
how do we judge
uh the correct level of anthropocentrism
like i am a human being
i am going to think about human beings
more than i am going to think about
daffodils that's just true
right you know a daffodil is going to
think about daffodils more than they
think about human beings
i presume unless they're being stomped
on by a human being
but you know it's just perfectly natural
and okay to think about
people and things that are in similar
circumstances to you
um how much to do that is a
is a good question um so i don't know
that's a very vague answer uh
sorry i could i should have put more
thought into this one maybe um
i so i i guess the the short answer if
i'm trying to be more direct is
i don't think it's true that we need to
work as a species on viewing ourselves
less
centrally i think we need to work as a
species
on viewing everything else more
uh definitely more carefully more
thoughtfully right more consciously
so there is the rest of the world the
rest of the universe out there the rest
of the biosphere the rest of the species
here on earth
uh species may be on other planets or
whatever and
we should take them into consideration
when we're doing what we do to the earth
but i don't think i don't think that the
problem is we're putting our species
first i think that individuals put
themselves first right
individuals uh work for the betterment
of themselves and their families and
whatever their friends
and we need cooperation as we discussed
way at the beginning of this
ama across people look around the globe
to do better like that's the more
important thing than we should think
about other species in particular
mikko hatan hat tainan says
how visual is your thinking i remember
you specifically mentioning visualizing
things in several podcast episodes
when talking about higher dimensions in
physics and math you mentioned that
visualization can only get you
so far so yeah so actually there's two
things
um number one i am actually kind of a
visual thinker
myself you know within mathematical
approaches or either to math or to
physics some people think
visually geometrically roughly speaking
you know drawing pictures and
and thinking about physically tangible
constructions and other people are more
equation based
thinking more abstractly in that sense
and in that continuum i'm more on the
drawing pictures
side of things i would love to someday
write a paper where i prove a result or
derive a result
just based on pictures without any
equations at all
but at the same time i recognize that it
does only take you so far
if you want to talk about a hilbert
space that is
10 to 120 dimensional or 10 to the 10 to
120 dimensional
um you can't visualize that give up you
can visualize three dimensions
and that's not a very uh representative
sample of 10 to the 10 to 120
dimensions so then you need to use the
math so
i can prefer to do things visually and i
can
try to use simple examples where i can
draw it to get as much intuition as i
can muster
but at the end of the day you got to
trust the math if you have a
mathematical description that works
where you understand it
then you should trust it where you can't
visualize it until you have a good
reason not to i think that's the rule of
thumb
okay two questions i'm gonna group
together because they're both about the
fermi paradox
uh why haven't we seen intelligent
aliens ken wolfe says what do you think
is the most likely solution to the fermi
paradox which is the one you would most
like to be true
and david wright says i've always been
very skeptical of media stories about
any physical encounters with
extraterrestrial intelligent beings
based on a simple fact isn't it vastly
more likely
that we would detect extraterrestrials
from their electromagnetic radiation
long before we would encounter their
matter so to david's question first
um i am always extremely skeptical
about anyone who says isn't it vastly
more likely that aliens would do this
rather than that
you know i don't know what aliens would
do i think we should be open-minded you
know other than the fact that
they have very very advanced technology
right presumably like by construction
it's extraordinarily unlikely that
advanced technological aliens would be
more or less at our level
of technology that's just an incredible
fine-tuning it's easy for them to be
millions of years further along in their
development right no problem at all
so whatever we think about uh
extraterrestrial
technol technological civilizations we
should assume that they're
much more technologically advanced what
that means
is very hard so no i don't think it's
necessarily true we would encounter
their electromagnetic radiation long
before we encounter their matter
in fact i could come up with the
perfectly plausible reason why the
opposite is true
the thing about electromagnetic
radiation is it zips right by you
right if you're an alien civilization
who wants to
make contact with other civilizations
elsewhere in the universe
electromagnetic radiation is the dumbest
thing to use
because not only do does the
civilization you're trying to target
need to be listening into you they need
to be listening into you at exactly the
right time
otherwise the photons just go right by
or radio waves or whatever
if you really want to sort of spread
through the galaxy and talk to everyone
who's in other solar systems
you should send space probes you should
send matter why because you can
park them there you can send a probe to
another solar system
and just have it wait there for a few
billion years to see if any intelligent
life comes into existence you can
integrate over time
in a way that you can't with
electromagnetic radiation not to mention
the fact that electromagnetic radiation
being beamed out into space is just
incredibly wasteful
and why would an advanced technological
civilization waste all that energy
now i don't think that either one of
these arguments
is actually convincing because i don't
know what extraterrestrials would do
other than the fact that they would be
technologically very advanced um for
ken's question what do i think is the
most likely solution i mean
the most likely solution is that the
probability of life arising on a
planet a planet that can um
in principle support life is small
one chance in 10 to 100. there you go
there's a number
that would make it very very unlikely
that there is even one other uh
life supporting planet in our um
observable universe now maybe life is
everywhere
but multicellular life is very very rare
or
uh eukaryotic life or the equivalent
thereof or
intelligent life or technological life
like maybe there's lots of intelligent
life everywhere in the universe but
they're all
swimming in the oceans and they have
flippers and they never develop
opposable thumb so they never build
spaceships right
um any of these are possible so i think
the most likely solution is that the
intelligent spacefaring civilizations
just aren't there
for some reason or another it's not the
only solution and again i think we
should be humble about these things but
that's the most obvious
likely one to me russell wolf
says how does entropy work with hawking
radiation if a black hole is a maximum
entropy object does that mean that it as
it evaporates its entropy decreases
no does not mean that because a black
hole is not a maximum entropy
object this is one of those cases where
you have to listen very carefully when
the physicists say their words
a black hole is the maximum entropy that
you can fit
into a region of prescribed size
so when a black hole evaporates it's
important that not only it creates
photons that leave the black hole but
those photons
spread out amongst a across a huge
distance
so the overall entropy of the radiation
that a black hole turns into
is higher than the entropy of the black
hole itself not by a lot
by a factor of order unity but it is
bigger but that entropy is spread out
over an enormous distance so there's no
contradiction with the fact that black
holes are
the maximum entropy you can have in a
region because the entropy they turn
into is not confined to that region it's
spread out
david frank says a few months back you
had avilaban talking about amumua
avi shortly thereafter took a lot of
criticism for his views what's your
honest view about his ideas on amumua
is he a charlatan selling snake oil or
is there some level of credibility to
his ideas
so again there's two things i want to
say about this number one
i i don't know if this came through in
the podcast but i don't care about a
muammua
like that is not the point to me what i
was interested in
is the general question of how should we
think about
taking seriously the idea of intelligent
life on other planets
in some sense contacting us or being
contactable
or having an influence or sending
something by our solar system
this particular example of a mova i
don't care
i don't think we'll have any information
that is going to let us decide one way
or the other so what is the point
of worrying about this particular
artifact i'm very interested in you know
should we be on the lookout for
artifacts like that what is the
probability what is the credence that we
should put into such ideas
so that's what i cared about the other
thing the other point to make is
i absolutely think it's it's wrong to
think of avi loeb as a charlatan selling
snake oil
um number one he's not i know that he's
not i know avi i know his work it's
it's very off-base think he's a
charlatan selling snake oil
number two um i am not going to have
charlatans who i think are selling snake
oil onto my podcast that's just not what
i am about
i do not if i ever invite someone on the
podcast i may or may not agree with them
but i will always think that they're
worth listening to and talking in good
faith
maybe i'm wrong like maybe they have
fooled me that's always possible right
but if i have someone on the podcast
you can take as given that i think
they're worth listening to
whether or not i think that they're
right i want the audience to get
something out of what they're saying i
will never have someone on the podcast
just to debunk them there's plenty of
that out there in the world
that's not what i'm about i'm about
listening to people who have something
interesting to teach us and i definitely
think that avi is on that
side of things whether or not he's right
about this particular event
dan pai says regarding your claim
building on frank wilcheck's core theory
that we are overwhelmingly
unlikely to discover another particle or
force that is relevant to our everyday
lives at the human scale
can you give an overview of how quantum
field theory tells us about what we know
we don't know so to speak
i.e how are we certain that there aren't
forces affecting normal matter
that simply aren't produced by any of
the common interactions generated in
particle accelerators
um so i'll give a short answer here
because i did write a paper on this
very recently the quantum field theory
on which everyday life supervenes and
i've tweeted about it
so you can find it pretty easily but you
know it's on it's you know you google
that you'll find it
um the point is quantum field theory
gives us rules it's not anything goes
so uh the particular rule that is
relevant here is one called crossing
symmetry
if you have a field or a particle that
can affect the fields and particles of
which we are made
then it is inevitable that you can make
that particle or make that field just by
colliding together
the particles and fields of which we are
made and that's what particle physics do
for a living they collide together
electrons and positrons or protons and
protons and antiprotons whatever
we smash particles together and look at
what comes out
if there were any other particles that
could that interact strongly enough with
the particles we're made of that they
could be relevant for human life
we would have made them already unless
there is something dramatically wrong
about quantum field theory that's always
possible so it's not a proof
of anything science doesn't prove things
but it means that it's telling you
exactly how dramatically you have to
violate the known laws of physics
in order to make something like that
happen
adam lowett says what are your thoughts
on the position held by former mindscape
mindscape guest stuart russell and
others
that artificial intelligent alignment ai
safety
could present a major challenge or even
an existential risk to humanity in the
future
so i have mixed feelings about this um
you know you use the phrase ai alignment
ai safety and these are these are two
different things
ai safety i think is a big deal i think
we should worry about it you know
and but it's not even ai safety it's
just complex systems
risk analysis okay we have computers we
have technology we have networks
uh that no one human being can grasp the
whole thing in their head
right no one human being can grasp the
whole internet and all of its details
or any uh sufficiently sophisticated
uh deep learning algorithm or something
like that you know it does things and no
human being knows exactly why it's doing
what it is doing okay
so there are obvious risks associated
with that kind of thing
long before you get to the point where
you would call call it artificially
intelligent
i think that's a general question how do
you quantify risks and how do you
protect yourself against risks for
complex systems which you don't fully
understand that's a very very important
question that we should put a lot of
effort into
the ai alignment problem as i understand
it and i'm not an expert although i've
had people
on the program talking about it um
what is being aligned here the alignment
is between the values
of the ai and the values that we human
beings have that is to say
once you have an artificially
intelligent system
that can be said to have values in some
sense
are its values our values are its values
once we would hold does it does it want
the same things that we want
to me that whole discussion seems
wrong-headed
a little bit i mean there's aspects of
it that make perfect sense but
it is way jumping the gun for sort of
for exactly the reasons that sort of are
implicit in what i just said about ai
safety
um who's to say that the word values
is something that even makes sense when
we're talking about artificial
intelligence
it seems highly anthropomorphic to me
to think that we can talk about the
values of an ai
in more or less the same way that we can
talk about the values of human beings
and therefore we can talk about aligning
them together i mean
maybe something that we would recognize
as artificially intelligent
has something we would recognize as
values maybe it doesn't maybe they're
similar to human values maybe they're
not who knows i mean i think that
there's this
this whole assumption that we get to
choose what the values are
and i've always worried about that
assumption i mean if it's really
artificially intelligent
can't it modify its own values in ways
that we can't predict
so i just think that that whole
discussion is based on
taking the analogy between ai and human
thinking too seriously
that's not to say i don't think that
ai's can't in principle do
anything that humans can do i'm not
giving humans any special status here
but just because in principle an ai
could do what a human can do
doesn't mean that in practice when you
get ai it will be human-like
in any way i presume that there are
thousands millions who knows how many
other ways to be intelligent that are
different from what humans
do and maybe the ai will be one of those
and maybe it'll have values that we can
recognize maybe it won't
right so i think it just it's asking the
wrong question to ask about the values
of ai what we should focus on is this
more general safety problem risk
management problem that's something i
think we should worry about
okay thomas freeman says do you feel
like you are always
on when it comes to your life as a
physicist meaning when you are watching
basketball or out to dinner with your
wife could you instantly chat about the
newest developments
etc um i think it depends here you know
i when i read the question for the first
time i was thinking i'm going to say no
i'm not always on because
in the sense that certainly there are
plenty of times in my life and i'm not
thinking about physics at all
okay when i'm thinking about basketball
or poker or wine or whatever it is
um but i think maybe that's not exactly
what you're asking in
retrospect i mean maybe what you're
asking is are there little subroutines
running beneath the surface
that are sort of physics-oriented that
could be summoned up
at any time or or might like secretly
affect how i think about basketball or
poker or wine or something like that
and there maybe yeah like maybe i do
think
that you know to go back to talking
about the physics of democracy
i do think that there is something
called thinking like a physicist
and it's not a single thing there are
ways that physicists
think there are sort of paradigms
questions that we ask you know toy
systems spherical cows that we regularly
refer to
ways of analyzing complex systems and
these pop up
in all sorts of different examples you
know you
you don't want to be the person watching
movies who constantly complains about
them not
obeying the laws of physics but you know
you do notice when they don't obey the
laws of physics
that is always there so i'm certainly
not always thinking about physics
consciously
but maybe it is it is true that there
are ways i am thinking about it
unconsciously all the time that i i'm
not quite sure but i'm willing to
uh believe in that okay very last
question
comes from brad miller who says do you
always
feel as confident in yourself as you
sound
so i guess i should thank you brad for
the implicit compliment that i always
sound confident or maybe it's not
you didn't actually assign a value
judgment to whether or not
sounding confident was good or bad uh
maybe you think it's it's objectionable
i don't know
but um i don't think
here i am sounding not very confident
about my level of confidence so
i don't think i'm very confident about
all sorts of things but
maybe there is and i'm just
this might not be true but maybe there
is a way to sound
confident just by being comfortable
about quantifying your uncertainty right
i mean what i do
try to do and i don't always succeed but
what i try to do
is to have a pretty good handle
on not just what i think is true but the
relative levels of confidence
i have in different things that i
believe right
um when i think that things are true i
try very hard
to be clear about why i think that those
are true could be clear to myself right
not going
badgering other people about why i think
it's true but you know understanding how
i came to these different points of view
so
and when you sort of take that attitude
about the world
that you should judge things with
different credences
and you should be clear as you can be
about
what the reasons are for having
different credences in different things
um then you i guess you start sounding
confident about it but even if what
you're saying is oh i have no idea
right uh many things i have no idea
about um and i'm
i'm happy to say that i'm not bothered
by it i'm not in other words
maybe i'm again i'm not at all confident
about this one but
maybe the appearance of of not being
confident
comes from feeling bad when you say
i don't know you know what i mean so
being able to say
i don't know anything about that thing
or i think this is true but it might go
away
even though you're actually expressing a
great deal of uncertainty
you're doing it in a way that makes you
sound confident and maybe that
is good maybe that is actually a virtue
that you can aim for
um being upfront about
what you know and what you don't know
right again
recognizing that you're always going to
be wrong sometimes you can't tell ahead
of time which times that's the problem
but um you can be confident that you're
gonna be wrong even if you're very
confident
that you have judged your credences as
well as you can
so maybe that's an answer brad i don't
know not very confident answer
thank you for the implicit conf
compliment if it were indeed there
uh i mean also i should also admit what
are you listening to me talk about
you're listening to me talk about things
on my podcast you know i get to choose
the
the topics right and so um and i get
that the questions that are being asked
are
questions about things that i usually
have talked about in the past one way or
the other
so you're not seeing a representative
sample about things that i could talk
about in the whole world you're seeing
me talk about things i know something
about
generally a little bit uh maybe that
also gives you a misimpression of the
confidence level anyway
something to think about these are good
questions that was a good question
lots of good questions i really had fun
with this ama
see you next month bye
[Music]
you